l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution visant à
améliorer le suivi des ordonnances
rénover le droit de pétition renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle du sénat mieux
utiliser le temps de séances publiques
et renforcer la parité
présentée par monsieur gérard larcher
président du sénat dans la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur
françois noël buffet rapporteur de la
commission des lois constitutionnelles
de la législation du suffrage universel
du règlement et de l'administration
générale pour dix minutes cher collègue
madame la présidente
mais à messieurs chers collègues la
proposition de résolution visant à
améliorer le suivi des ordonnances
rénover le droit de pétition et
renforcer les pouvoirs de contrôle du
sénat fait suite au groupe de travail
sur la modernisation des méthodes de
travail du sénat qui a réuni tous les
groupes politiques du mois de décembre
dernier au mois de mars c'est la
présidence de notre président gérard
larcher sur le rapport de pascale gruny
vice-présidente du sénat
ce groupe de travail a adopté 39
propositions dont 14 nécessitait une
modification de notre règlement tel est
l'objet de la proposition de résolution
déposée par le président et qui poursuit
cinq objectifs le premier de ceux-ci et
l'amélioration le suivi des ordonnant et
d'améliorer par dont le suivi d
ordonnance prise sur le fondement des
dispositions de l'article 38 de la
constitution
la proposition de résolution temps
d'abord à ajouter aux missions des
commissions permanentes le suivi des
ordonnances a consacré la compétence de
la commission saisie au fond pour
déclarer irrecevables les amendements
présentés par les sénateurs contraire
aux dispositions de l'article 38 de la
constitution et renforcer l'information
du sénat sur les intentions du
gouvernement
en matière de publications et de
ratification d'ordonnancés
le deuxième objectif est la volonté de
rénover les modalités d'exercice du
droit de pétition
s'inspirant des modalités expérimentale
mise en oeuvre depuis le mois de janvier
2020 la proposition de résolution visant
à rénover ses modalités d'exercice
déposée par principe sur une plateforme
électronique tout pétition qui
atteindrait un seuil de signature fixée
par le bureau du sénat
je dis bien fixée par le bureau du sénat
serait évoqué en conférence des
présidents qui déciderait des suites à
lui donner
par dérogation cette instance pourrait
être également se saisir d'une pétition
n'ayant pas atteint ce seuil
au vu de certains critères qui devraient
être alors défini par le bureau
le troisième objectif est de renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle du sénat à cet
effet la proposition résolution temps à
prévoir d'abord la désignation d'un
rapporteur sur les nominations dont les
commissions sont saisis en application
de la procédure de l'article 13 de la
constitution
la deuxième chose c'est la
simplification de l'attribution des
prérogatives de commission denquête à
une commission permanente ou spéciale
lorsque le sénat ne siège pas le
troisième c'est la fixation à 23 du
plafond des membres des commissions
d'enquêté mission d'information tout en
permettant d'y déroger sur décision de
la conférence des présidents pour les
structures créées hors droits de tirage
des groupes politiques
enfin c'est l'accélération de l'examen
en séance d'une question écrite restées
sans réponse qui serait alors transformé
en question orale quatrième objectif une
meilleure utilisation du temps de séance
publique
c'est peut-être là que les choses se
gâtent un peu
mais il faut rappeler que la proposition
de résolution temps également à réduire
de deux minutes et demie à deux minutes
la durée de droit commun des
interventions de sénateurs et de 10 à 3
minutes la durée de présentation des
motions de procédure qui n'émane ni du
gouvernement ni de la commission ni d'un
groupe politique ainsi que celle de
l'intervention de l'orateur d'opinion
contraire elle supprime le renvoi enfin
de tourniquets de l'orateur du groupe
auquel appartient le rapporteur lors de
la discussion générale et institue une
procédure allégée d'examen du texte
élaboré par une commission mixte
paritaire
enfin elle tend à créer une motion de
procédure haddock tendance à ne pas
examiner une proposition de loi déposé
en application de l'article 11 de la
constitution pour permettre au sénat
d'obtenir l'organisation d'un référendum
d'initiative partager l'émotion
existantes ne répondons pas qu'on ne
répond donc pas totalement ou
complètement à cette exigence
enfin le cinquième objectif c'est celui
d'assurer la parité au sein du bureau du
sénat
l'article 14 de la proposition de
résolution seront à prévoir que les
listes établies par les groupes en vue
de l'élection des membres du bureau du
sénat je cite s'efforce d'assurer une
représentation équilibrée entre les
femmes et les hommes pour chacune de ces
fonctions
l'ensemble de ces dispositions seraient
susceptibles d'entrer en vigueur pour
l'ouverture de notre prochaine session
ordinaire c'est-à-dire le 1er octobre
naturellement après avoir été soumise au
contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
votre commission a approuvé cette
démarche présentée par le président
larcher et n'a apporté que quelques
précisions et compléments
la proposition de résolution nous avons
prévu que la transmission du calendrier
de publication des ordonnances par le
gouvernement portent sur le semestre
sans se limiter à la session ordinaire
nous avons également intégré par
cohérence au sein de l'article 44 bis de
notre règlement la compétence de la
commission au fond pour déclarer
irrecevable les amendements présentés
par les sénateurs qui serait contraire
aux dispositions de l'article 38 de la
constitution
s'agissant des pétitions la commission
des lois approuvées l'exclusion de tout
automaticité lier un seuil de signatures
pour préserver en dernier ressort le
pouvoir d'appréciation des instances du
sénat est la clarifier les compétences
entre le bureau du sénat habilité à
déterminer les règles de recevabilité de
caducité et de publicité des pétitions
et la conférence des présidents
seul juge de l'opportunité des suites à
leur donner ainsi le rôle de chacune de
ces instances serait parfaitement
déterminé sur les pouvoirs de contrôle
du sénat la commission a modifié la
procédure prévue à l'article 6
la proposition de résolution sur
l'approbation tacite par le sénat de
l'attribution de prérogatives de
commission denquête à une commission
permanente ou spéciale lorsque toujours
le sénat ne siège pas dans cette
hypothèse il reviendrait aux seuls
présidents de la commission des lois
indépendamment de la personnalité qui
occupe la fonction d'examiner la
conformité de cette demande avec
l'article 6 de l'ordonance du 17
novembre 1958 elle même relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires
après consultation de ses membres enfin
la commission a adopté trois amendements
portant article additionnel clarifiant
au corrigeant diverses dispositions du
règlement notamment sur le dépôt et
l'examen des questions orales
l'objectif étant véritablement de
simplifier les choses
they dans la mission qui a été la mienne
reçu un certain nombre de contributions
de collègues présidents de groupe ou
présidents de commissions également reçu
un certain nombre de collègues en rendez
vous pour pouvoir échanger d'autres je
lui dis à ces tribunes très gentiment
n'ont rien demandé ni à être reçus il ya
contribué par écrit je le dis
sincèrement sans aucune acrimonie c'est
dommage ça aurait permis peut-être
d'approfondir un peu plus la discussion
en revanche un certain nombre
d'amendements sont déposés un peu plus
d'une cinquantaine dans la très grande
majorité d'entre eux vont à l'encontre
de la position de la commission mais
nous aurons naturellement l'occasion
nous ont expliqué au cours de cette fin
d'après midi
merci à tous et à toutes de votre
attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à monsieur
guillaume gontard pour le groupe des
écologistes pour cinq minutes chers
collègues
merci madame madame la présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues
cette ppr est le fruit de plusieurs
réunions de travail sous la houlette du
président larcher de notre rapporteur
madame pascale gruny si nous saluons
l'initiative et la volonté de faire
évoluer notre règlement notamment
regardé l'épisode sanitaire que notre
traversée
nous regrettons cependant le manque
d'ambition et d'ouverture
disons-le la présente résolution ne
bouleversera pas le fonctionnement de
notre institution
nous y voyons une occasion manquée
d'ouvrir davantage le sénat vers
l'extérieur et de garantir les droits de
l'opposition gage d'une démocratie
vivante
ce texte comporte certes quelques
avancées je ne reviendrai pas sur les
mesures techniques et de bon sens
présentée par le président buffet nous
saluons les propositions pour renforcer
notamment le suivi des ordonnances
législatives que selon ce que cela soit
dans l'émission des commissions leurs
moyens ou dans les obligations à
l'endroit du gouvernement
tout cela va bien sûr dans le bon sens
pandémie ou pas l'explosion de la
législation par ordonnance et le mâle
démocratique de notre temps la loi ne se
fait pas dans l'urgence et à l'abri des
regards dans les administrations
ministérielles
c'est une révision complète de l'article
38 de notre constitution qu'il faudrait
entreprendre mais ce n'est pas le débat
du moment
en attendant cette échéance nous
soutenons cette proposition et en
profitons pour inviter le sénat a cessé
de se dessaisir si souvent de son
pouvoir législatif
les mesures pour renforcer les pouvoirs
de contrôle sont aussi plus intéressante
même si elle ne révolutionne rien
simplifier la constitution de commission
denquête pour faire face à une nouvelle
affaire benalla en plein été tout cela
est naturellement souhaitable mais nous
demeurons très loin de la mission de
contrôle du pouvoir exécutif dévolu aux
assemblées de régime parlementaire digne
de ce nom
pour prendre un exemple d'actualité
alors que doit paraître demain le
rapport du gouvernement sur les
exportations d'armes de la france
nous n'avons absolument aucun droit de
regard sur la chose en matière de
contrôle il faudrait un jour que nous
nous pencherons sur les décrets
d'application des lois que nous votons
trop souvent le gouvernement des faits
par
pouvoir réglementaire la loi que nous
votons sans que nous ayons ni droit de
regard ni moyens d'action mais pour
revenir au présent texte renforcer le
droit de pétition pour tenir compte de
l'expérimentation conduite depuis 18
mois est une bonne chose mais cela est
bien timide nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens sont avides de participation
démocratique et ce que nous leur
proposons six cent mille d'entre eux le
demande c'est d'envisager peut-être un
jour d'examiner leurs textes
nous allons créer plus de frustration
qu'autre chose il faut systématiser
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de
toutes les propositions recevable quitte
à relever le seuil de quoi avez vous
peur
le parlement reste souverain pour
rejeter le texte in fine et sur ce point
nous regrettons vivement que le sar est
au milieu du gué et nous ferons des
propositions à travers un amendement
j'en viens au pointu problématique
la réduction du temps de parole en
séance pour favoriser la vitalité
démocratique
le groupe écologiste proposé d'augmenter
le temps de parole réservée aux groupes
d'opposition et d'allonger les
explications de vote sur les motions de
procédure loin nous entendre vous
souhaitez réduire notre temps de parole
en séance
c'est incompréhensible cessons
d'accélérer en permanence la fabrication
de la loi on vote près d'un texte par
semaine c'est la garantie du travail mal
fait nous n'avons pas à nous plier à un
calendrier qui n'est pas le nôtre
nous n'avons pas nous presser encore
davantage pour examiner les lois de
circonstance et ainsi servir de faire
valoir à la communication politique des
gouvernements particulièrement dans
cette maison où le presto l'obstruction
n'existe pas et où chacun est
respectueux de la bonne tenue des débats
cette mesure est arithmétiquement plus
pénalisante pour les petits groupes qui
avec un nombre d'orateurs limitée
verront leurs possibilités d'expression
d'autant plus réduite
par ailleurs cette mesure pourrait même
à terme s'avérer contre-productive vous
prenez le risque d'une multiplication du
nombre d'amendements pour créer des
espaces de parole cela me semble absurde
cela peut se justifier pour les
questions orales ou les débats de
contrôle en échange d'un nombre
d'orateurs accrue pour le travail de la
loi c'est particulièrement inacceptable
en l'état si aucun des amendements de
article 11 les adopter le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
votera contre cette proposition de
résolution
les timides avancées de ce texte sont
largement insuffisantes pour renforcer
les pouvoirs de notre assemblée
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à monsieur alain richard
pour le groupe rdp pour six minutes
chers collègues je suis en prime merci
monsieur le président de la commission
mes chers collègues
la discussion qui s'ouvre cet après midi
a été préparé par une et chant un
échange une concertation entre les
représentants des groupes qui s'est
déroulée dans un climat globalement
ouvert et constructif
bien que certains désaccords sont
apparus
le travail a été préparé par des
contributions soit orale soit écrite de
tous nos groupes et je souhaite à mon
tour salué le travail de synthèse et de
mise en ordre qui était très bien fait
par madame grünig comme rapporteur de ce
groupe de travail est bien entendu le
travail du président buffet ensuite
perfectionné disons-le ouvrage je ne le
souhaite mentionné que 3 des sujets qui
sont abordés par cette modification du
règlement n'est pas de grande ampleur et
est en réalité je n'entendais personne
réclamer un qu'une transformation
profonde du règlement du sénat
c'est normal doit évoluer modérément
avec le temps donc le premier sujet que
je souhaite évoquer et l'utilisation des
pétitions il est sans doute heureux que
cette assemblée soit ouverte à des
initiatives des citoyens mais la variété
même des thèmes qui seront abordés dans
ces pétitions et de la façon dont elles
auront été secrétaire en quelque sorte
aux soldats de la société par tel ou tel
mouvement par tel ou tel phénomène de
communication rend particulièrement
difficile d'adopter une règle de fond
qui soit permanence et qui s'appliquent
à tous les cas c'est la raison pour
laquelle
les auteurs de la modification et je
rejoins leur position préfère laisser un
pouvoir d'appréciation
dans tous les cas à la conférence des
présidents du sénat voir au bureau
lorsqu'il y aura énonciation d'un
critère numérique de nombre de
signataires je crois que c'est la
sagesse qu'on ne peut pas d' avance
affirmé que dans telle catégorie dans
quelle case seront forcément des
pétitions qui justifierait l'arrivée
jusqu'à la séance publique
et il vaut mieux je me semble-t-il
respecter ce pouvoir d'appréciation
d'autant plus que un souvenir quand même
qu'ils se perdent en temps mais qui a
gardé son importance
dans les débuts de l'application de la
constitution avait été le refus par le
général de gaulle de convoquer une
session extraordinaire de l'assemblée
nationale qui avait été réclamée par une
pétition des syndicats agricoles au nom
d'un article de la constitution contre
l'utilisent pas très souvent mais qui
remonte à la tradition républicaine qui
est que tout mandat impératif est nul
ensuite le sujet de l'examen en cours de
vie si j'ose dire des ordonnances ça je
pense que c'est une bonne création la
modification du règlement ne peut pas
avoir pour effet de limiter le pouvoir
du gouvernement de demander et d'obtenir
si le vote va dans ce sens des
habilitations à réaliser des ordonnances
mais il clarifie le processus de leurs
débouchés sous forme d'adoption
ordonnance et permet ou à l'assemblée
enfin au sénat en l'occurrence de bien
connaître la sortie des différentes
ordonnances ne permettre aussi à ces
commissions dans l'analyse et le contenu
et par conséquent les consuls et
commissions pourront suggérer des
initiatives notamment parce que dans le
cas d'une ordonnance
si l' ordonnance n'a pas fait de
bouleversements et respecte loyalement
l'objet qui était celui de
l'habilitation qui a été consenti par le
parlement il n'y a pas énormément de
sujets de querelle
en revanche s'il y a un débordement ou
s'il y a dix ont une mauvaise
interprétation par l'exécutif de
l'habilitation il est important que le
parlement soit informé suffisamment tôt
pour pouvoir prendre une initiative
législative qui permettent de corriger
une un dérapage
donc cette nouvelle procédure de vian
sur les ordonnances me paraît de nature
à assurer la bonne le bon dialogue la
bonne concertation entre l'exécutif et
nos assemblées enfin je n'aborderai dam
d'un mot la sphère de la réduction du
temps de parole de droit commun
c'est-à-dire la la réduction à deux
minutes de nos créneaux d'expression en
séance publique
je rappelle bien que on est en séance
publique c'est à dire que
il ya tout un travail de commission
lorsqu'on évoque la fabrication de la
loi nous savons tous que le pluralisme
et le temps de réflexion s'applique
d'abord dans le travail de commission
pour lesquels nous avons des délais
souvent un peu contraint enfin qu permet
tout de même de bien préparer le travail
de s'informer de diab dialoguer au sein
des groupes et par conséquent la
limitation du temps de parole ne pèse
que sur l'examen final en séance
publique du travail qui a déjà été
concertés et approfondie et je crois que
dans tous les parlements
il y à des dispositifs qui aboutissent à
faire tenir dans le temps disponible
les travaux parlementaires et notamment
législatif est bien souvent ces
mécanismes de contraintes porte sur le
droit d'amendement lui-même c'est-à-dire
que leur beaucoup de parlement le nombre
d'amendements n'est pas aussi largement
calculé que dans notre dans notre propre
constitution et donc au fond la
limitation du temps de parole individuel
aux séances publiques
il est la contrepartie d'un pluralisme
qui veut que nous soyons nombreux à
souhaiter intervenir sur tel ou tel
article et que si tout le monde prend un
temps un peu plus long évidemment ça a
un effet soit de prolonger abusivement
les séances et de perdre de l'intérêt et
l'attention des membres soit de priver
des collègues de temps de parole donc il
me semble que ce n'est pas un mauvais
compromis
surtout que quand on regarde comment es
tu écris de règlement c'est toujours
sous l'appréciation du président de
séance et savons bien que le président
de séance fond elle est présidente
encore mieux font preuve de discernement
il ne coupe pas la parole à la 151e
seconde des orateurs le dans le cas
actuel
donc il me semble que cette modeste
réforme contribuera plus tôt à la vie
disons activé et
on dira dynamique de nos de nos débats
et c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
groupe apportera son soutien à ces
mesures de modification du règlement
merci chers collègues
j'appelle à présent le président jean
claude requier du groupe rdse pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
coprésidant la présidence de monsieur a
planté un chat collègues en abidal à la
vie de notre assemblée a perdu de sa
vigueur georges rech jauge réduite dans
l'hémicycle multiplication parfois à
nous les hommes des visioconférences et
ou encore c'est triste mois tant
khartoum pour manger ces bouleversements
nous ont tout de même offert l'occasion
d'engager une réflexion sur
l'organisation du travail parlementaire
qui fut réalisé par un nouveau travail
rapporté par pascal gury danger
tellement duquel découle cette
proposition de résolution par les
expositions que ces textes comportent
certaines d'entre elles sont soutenues
par le groupe rdse
je pense d'abord à celles relatives au
suivi des corps ordonnance il est en
effet nécessaire et souhaitable
s'assurer que les commissions
permanentes dispose des outils
permettant un suivi plus efficace de
l'application des ordonnances surtout
dans un contexte où le gouvernement a
particulièrement sollicité le parlement
pour l'habilité à légiférer parfois main
dans des proportions excessives temps
soit forme que sur le fond il en va de
même l'article 4 qui nous vient
consacrer la mise à plat bien plate
forme numérique a mis les peaux et de la
centralisation des pétitions se dit il
nous paraît équilibré il favorise les
gars ils iront les pétitions semble pour
autant porter atteinte à l'inversé du
sénat de l'organisation de son travail
en effet il n'est pas question est aussi
en droit de pétition
il permet de formaliser l'expression
d'une opinion l'exercice de démocratie
directe par nos concitoyens
toutefois il demeure essentiel
l'exercice de ce droit sont encadrés ils
ne viennent pas broyer les mécanismes
traditionnels vers démocratie
parlementaire
en revanche nous sommes beaucoup plus
réservée sur ces dispositions relatives
aux règles discussion en séance publique
en premier lieu d'interdire propose
l'examen c'est en été créée d'abord et
par une commission mixte paritaire pour
al objets sort décision contraire quand
on est président d'une procédure
simplifiée conférant la commission
saisie au fond et à chaque jour
politique un temps identique de cinq
minutes
nous comprenons la nécessité qui peut y
avoir à vouloir optimiser l'utilisation
et en séance publique
toutefois pourquoi réserver à c'est là
qu'on verra des présidents le droit de
relancer allégé d'une procédure
simplifiée cela peut paraître excessif à
l'image et la procédure simplifiée
utilisé pour l'examen des préventions
internationale vous approchez
législation en commission nous pourrions
prévoir que briand européens puissent
disposer du pouvoir et l'emmener le
retour en procédure normale pour
l'examen des conclusions d'une
commission mixte paritaire en seconde et
surtout la proposition vous réduire à 2
minutes au lieu de 30
la durée droit commun des interventions
des sénateurs je crois que ça serait
pour menaces traîne à nous mêmes une
atteinte excessive à notre liberté de
parlementaires veulent encore plus
récemment le groupe numériquement moins
important qu'en l'autre pour lesquels le
temps alloué en discussion générale déjà
assez limité d'aucune loi n'est en fin
de nuit raconte traînement excessivement
le débat aurait série limitée ou de
caricaturer une telle mesure constitue
donc pour nous une érection écrire du
temps de parole est membre a semblé
alors que des voix et sas du parlement
ces deux points nous n'avons été déposée
à leur espoir qu'ils puissent courrier
c'est bien je conclurai y avoir les mots
quand la question de la parité
chacun souscrire évidemment besoin qu'au
sénat en plusieurs langues société la
parité somme est respectée toutefois
pour les groupes petite taille tels que
notre les objectifs risquent de porter
indirectement une à tête entre liberté
de choix lorsqu'un groupe la faculté de
ne désigner que seulement motion de
l'engagisme collégial dans quel plaisir
peut-il envisager que la parité est
observée dans désignation de ce seuil
- la bonne solution c'est de trouver et
c'est pour y passer nos débats que nous
y tiendrons
car autre groupe reste naturellement
volontaires pour avancer sur ces
questions même lorsqu'elle se heurte à
18 et pratiques réelles
pour conclure on regarde les éléments
notre groupe entame alger travaux des
amendements pour se positionner c'est au
texte merci chers collègues
j'appelle à présent la présidente à
celle ci pour prendre la parole pour un
temps de 5 minutes cher présidente
enfin madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues c'est donc pour la
troisième fois en six ans que notre
assemblée remet sur le canevas son
règlement je le dis d'emblée notre
déception est importante car nous
aurions pu penser que l'affaiblissement
constatée par tous du parlement du
législatif face à un exécutif en
particulier lors de la crise sanitaire
aurait débouché sur une réflexion
relative aux moyens d'intervention du
parlement aux moyens d'action et pas
seulement de contrôler avec les missions
de contrôle qui ressemble trop souvent
un lot de consolation pour un parlement
a baissé du point de vue législatif
monsieur le président du sénat ne cesse
de répéter que le coeur du métier c'est
faire la loi
en quoi cette proposition de résolution
améliorera les pouvoirs du cdhal les
pouvoirs des parlementaires en la
matière en rien ou si peu de chose
depuis des années nous répétons
inlassablement une évidence pour
renforcer une institution il ne faut pas
amoindrir ses prêts roquettes ses
prérogatives essentielles la prérogative
essentielle du parlementaire et de faire
la loi et à ce titre de pouvoir susciter
le débat
exposer des arguments en un mot le droit
à la parole le droit à l'expression ce
temps d'expression
il est systématiquement rollier depuis
35 ans au nom de la rationalisation du
travail parlementaire
ce concept que nous considérons comme
profondément antidémocratique vise à
convaincre que débattre mais aussi
amendé je reviendrai ne serait pas
raisonnable
nous manquons de temps pour traiter avec
rigueur le nombre considérable de texte
qui nous est soumis mais qui en portent
la responsabilité
pourquoi n'est ce pas dit une fois pour
toutes le pouvoir exécutif qui suit si
depuis des années une formidable
inflation législative une frénésie de
réformes bien souvent imposés voir
obligé par les normes européennes les
responsables d'une éventuelle surchauffe
du parlement ne sont sûrement pas les
parlementaires eux-mêmes mais bien ceux
qui abreuve l'ordre du jour par des
textes trop souvent mal préparée
ou de circonstance les chats collègues
nous avons déjà beaucoup cédé nos
interventions sont parfois si courte
pour des sujets qui pourraient susciter
des thèses que le sens même du débat
peut se perdre
c'est de l'affaiblissement des échanges
du travail de la confrontation
pluraliste des idées que peuvent net
déséquilibre qui pourtant sont chères à
beaucoup d'entre vous aujourd'hui de
manière presque incongru sinon
provocatrice la majorité souhaite
réduire de 2 30 à 2 minutes le temps de
parole sur les interventions autre que
discussion générale motion procédure
pourtant 2015 et en 2019
le conseil constitutionnel avait édicté
une réserve d'interprétation sur cette
volonté dogmatique de contraindre le
droit d'expression des parlementaires
pourquoi cette mesure quelles leçons
tirez-vous de l'affaiblissement renforcé
de notre pouvoir depuis mars 2020
quelles leçons tirez-vous de la crise
politique en cours
souhaitez vous laisser le débat aux
seules chaînes d'information en continu
et aux seuls réseaux sociaux la
démocratie est intimement liée au temps
sans ce temps ce sera l'avènement de la
dictature de l'instant
cette proposition de résolution ne
retient aucunement les propositions d'un
débat sur l'état du droit d'amendement
émanant d'au moins deux groupes depuis
des années chacun ici se plaint souvent
hors micro malheureusement des excès
d'applications d irrecevabilité
constitutionnel concernant les
amendements nous avons déposé
volontairement plusieurs propositions
pour tenter d'obtenir des réponses pour
améliorer ce droit essentiel pour
l'existence du parlement l'exemple du
débat budgétaire est frappant la
réduction considérable du droit
d'amendement depuis l'application de la
lolf qui a amplifié les effets de
l'article 40 tu la discussion anil les
échanges sur des propositions
alternatives
peut-on parler de démocratie
parlementaire si la confrontation des
projets ne peut avoir lieu
cette proposition de résolution passe
donc selon nous à côté de l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'était de riposter au
projet constitutionnel d'emmanuel m'a
conquis visé justement les prérogatives
des assemblées en critiquant le manque
d'efficacité ou le temps perdu avec
monsieur le président du sénat nous
avons toutes et tous combattu cette
tentative dangereuse pour la démocratie
pourquoi ne
aujourd'hui agir pour redonner aux
débats toute sa force au sein du sénat
cette proposition de résolution met en
avant une amélioration du contrôle des
ordonnances bien mais vous savez tous
ici que temps que l'article 38 de la
constitution ne sera pas supprimée ou
encadrer la force des ordonnances pourra
difficilement être contrainte
enfin vous aménager le droit de pétition
cela pourrait être une action utile pour
l'exercice de la citoyenneté mais
pourquoi avoir placé l'exercice de ce
droit utiles sous le contrôle de la
majorité sénatoriale puisque c'est elle
qui décidera de la vie ou de la mort
d'une pétition vous proposeront par
amendement de desserrer l'étau pour
conclure nous avons du mal à saisir le
sens de cette énième réforme de nos
méthodes de travail qui ne répondra
certainement pas aux besoins
démocratique que j'ai évoquées au bout
du compte nous assistons à une
réaffirmation du fait majoritaire
assorti d'une nouvelle réduction des
prérogatives parlementaires le groupe
hier c e votera donc contre ce texte
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent monsieur loïc
hervé du groupe union centriste pour un
temps de 4 minutes vers cologne
madame la présidente madame la vice
présidente de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues le groupe de
l'union centriste salue l'initiative de
notre président gérard larcher d'avoir
constitué un groupe de travail
réunissant tous les groupes politiques
afin de réfléchir à la modernisation des
méthodes de travail de notre assemblée
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
le résultat de travaux auxquels chacun
des groupes politiques a pu contribuer
et le groupe de l'union centriste s'en
félicite
nous allons travail réalisé par le
groupe de travail nous estimons qu'il
apporte des réponses utiles et concrètes
à des problématiques rencontrées de
manière récurrente dans notre travail
parlementaire je pense notamment à
l'objectif poursuivi d'améliorer le
suivi d ordonnance prise sur le
fondement de l'article 38 de la
constitution cela vient d'être évoqué
c'est un fait le nombre d'ordonnancés
adopté en constante progression
notamment depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel
macron à l'elysée avec la crise
sanitaire un cap supplémentaire a été
franchi dans la présidentialisation de
notre régime par le recours récurrent à
cette pratique
s'ils peuvent parfois être utile leur
usage massif qui confine à un
gouvernement barre donne ans renforce
considérablement le poids du pouvoir
exécutif en matière législative et ceci
au détriment du parlement
c'est pourquoi renforcer les compétences
de nos commissions permanentes à travers
le suivi des ordonnances et la capacité
de pouvoir déclarer irrecevables les
amendements présentés par les sénateurs
ayant pour objectif de créer et tendre
rétablir une habilitation à légiférer
par ordonnances nous apparaît aller dans
le bon sens par ailleurs en tant que
membre de la délégation aux droits des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les femmes vous imaginez
bien mes chers collègues que je ne peux
que saluer la disposition qui vise à
assurer la parité au sein du bureau du
sénat
l'égalité femmes hommes et une cause qui
passe par une mobilisation de tous et le
sénat doit faire partie de ces
institutions qui donne l'exemple pour
que cette disposition vient d'inscrire
dans notre règlement une pratique déjà
bien réelle
notre institution doit garantir cette
égalité des chances entre les hommes et
les femmes
sir collègues maintenant en moins de
deux minutes je veux vous dire pourquoi
je pense que la réduction de 2 minutes
30 à 2000 à 2 minutes est une bonne
chose
je dois vous avouer d'abord que j'étais
un peu de prime abord interrogatif par
un des aspects de cette proposition
visant à avoir le temps de parole de
droit commun réduit je pense tout
particulièrement aux explications de
vote à la prise de parole sur article ou
à la présentation d'un amendement mais à
la réflexion je crois que cette
proposition de résolution ne fait que
poursuivre une évolution qui me semble
inéluctable au fil des dernières réforme
de notre règlement et finalement cette
évolution présente en creux un bénéfice
puisque elle conforte dé facto
l'importance des débats en commission
il a été rappelé plusieurs fois et à
juste titre que ces débats n'étaient pas
soumis à une limitation de temps
espérons que cela perdure et je pense en
particulier pour travaux de la
commission des lois au sein de laquelle
le temps
parole est libre même si le rythme
d'examen des amendements et souvent
rapide
aulas au delà de cette réflexion
personnelle sur le temps de parole et
sur la nécessité d'avoir une discussion
générale qui soit vivante
je tiens à saluer le travail de pascale
gruny ainsi que le travail du rapporteur
le président françois noël buffet pour
toutes ces raisons et sur l'ensemble de
ces éléments le groupe de l'union
centriste a souhaité s'unir avec la
majorité sénatoriale à laquelle il a
paris il appartient et donc voter cette
proposition de résolution je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent monsieur est votre éric
kerrouche pardon des groupes un
socialiste et vous allez lastminute
chers collègues
cette proposition de résolution n'est
pas un bouleversement notre règlement
intérieur il s'agit d'une suite
d'ajustement c'est la déclaration faite
sur un ton patelin du président de la
commission des lois pour résumé
l'ambition de la réforme du règlement
ces ajustements traduit selon nous une
toute autre volonté d'abord dans la
méthode
nous avons eu une concertation mais sans
le compromis si l'objectif de la roche
de cette réforme était partagé les
mesures qui en résultent ne font pas
consensus
si ce n'est celle qui concerne la le
référendum d'initiative partagée aucune
de nos propositions n'a été retenue
qu'elle était alors au final l'intérêt
d'organiser cinq réunions de travail
trans partisan pour finalement ne plus
aborder le fonctionnement du parlement
en temps de crise sans pour autant
cautionner l'idée d'un parlement à
distance mais tout simplement garantir
la continuité du parlement renvoyer la
discussion sur la mission de contrôle
parlementaire à la délégation du bureau
en charge du travail parlementaire
si ce n'est les quelques ajustements qui
ont été déjà présentés par quelques
autres orateurs et il fuit les
transcrire dans la proposition finale de
résolution les propositions initiales
qui étaient soumises aux groupes de
travail
j'aime assez peu les menus uniques au
restaurant parce qu'il ya toujours de
fortes probabilités d'être déçu dans la
suite des plats est en effet nous avons
quelques accords sur l'entrée mais pas
sur la suite du menu quelques accords
d'abord sur les mesures relatives au
suivi des ordonnances elles font
consensus
elle était d'autant plus nécessaire
suite à la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel
pour autant il est important que le
gouvernement l'entende
cette mesure ne vient pas cautionner le
véhicule des ordonnances que nous
souhaitons plutôt en d'idées en
encadrant l'article 38
quelques chiffres vous le savez la part
des ordonnances parmi l'ensemble des
taxes qui interviennent dans le domaine
de la loi dépasse désormais
systématiquement 50%
le délais d'adoption d'une loi est
inférieur de 200 jours au délai moyen
entre le dépôt de la demande
d'habilitation et la publication de
l'ordonance ces chiffres sont le symbole
d'une déposition inefficace du parlement
enfin vous le savez la pratique de
ratification des ordonnances enregistre
un recul significatif depuis le début de
ce quinquennat 70 % en moyenne depuis
2007 contre 28% dans le présent
quinquennat
les ordonnances sont de plus en plus
nombreuses les ratifications sont de
plus en plus rares ces chiffres sont
symptomatiques de la considération
accordée au parlement et donc de la
nécessité collective de préserver son
rôle nous partageons également les
mesures liées au renforcement des
pouvoirs de contrôle dont la réflexion
reste à poursuivre dans le cadre de la
délégation du bureau relative au travail
parlementaire dans une perspective
constructive nous avons déposé un
amendement relatif aux débats de
contrôle en commission que nous avons
évoquée pendant le groupe de travail
enfin bien entendu nous partageons la
création d'une motion adobe pour
permettre au céda d'obtenir
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée
cette mesure que nous avions soutenu est
proposé
revenons-en au plat de résistance nous
le bouton peu voire pas du tout les
points de désaccord tourne autour du
fait que contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu précédemment nous allons dans
l'affaiblissement de la place du
parlement et des droits de l'opposition
deux mesures cristallise l'opposition
cela déjà été évoquée la diminution du
temps de parole d'une part et la
suppression du tourniquet
d'autre part si ces mesures sont pour la
majorité sénatoriale des ajustements que
l'on ne fasse pas croire qu'il s'agit
d'ajustements qui sont anodins elles
traduisent un affaiblissement des droits
de l'opposition et donc du parlement
cette réforme selon nous se fait au
détriment de la qualité de la loi
est-ce qu'il faut devenir le parlement
de la vitesse
est-ce qu'il faut s'inscrire sans cesse
dans la course temps législatif dans les
pas de l'exécutif cette évolution ne
fait que confirmer les dires d'armes
outre aux âmes notre société à rapport
pathologique autant et c'est une
aliénation dont il faut savoir se
défaire l'évolution proposée entre en
contradiction avec ce qui nous importe
est que le public et que le sénat pardo
défend d'ordinaire la qualité de la loi
et la place du parlement face à un
exécutif qui abusent des procédures
accélérées
nous sommes déjà l'un des parlements les
plus faibles des démocraties
occidentales et la majorité nous propose
encore de l'affaiblir je rappelle que la
limite du temps de parole au bundestag
pour les parlementaires est de 15
minutes au sénat américain certes moins
nombreux la limite de temps et de 20
minutes mais à la chambre des
représentants qui compte 4 135
parlementaires la limite est de 5
minutes et à westminster il n'y a pas de
limite du temps de parole pour le chef
de l'opposition la majorité sénatoriale
nous propose de parler toujours - alors
même qu'il n'y a aucune possibilité de
filibustering
c'est à dire de prises de paroles des
voiliers au sénat le débat est essentiel
pour que les idées s'affrontent et cela
contribue aussi à l'élaboration d'une
loi de qualité tout autant qu'à la santé
démocratique
cette mesure traduit en fait
l'intériorisation de plusieurs idées que
nous combattons le parlement prendrait
trop de temps
il est du temps perdu
inefficace donc trop cher donc devient
inutile avec ce raisonnement on pourrait
toujours rationalité rationaliser
jusqu'à disparaître
le parlement devrait ensuite être
subordonnée aux désirs de célérité de
l'exécutif seul métronome de la vie
politique au détriment de la fabrication
de la loi et enfin les oppositions
devraient être les moins audible
possible en réduisant leurs droits est
ici leur temps global d'intervention
cette mesure et cette impression est à
renforcer par la modification mesquine
de la règle du tourniquet pour nous il
s'agit d'une modernisation de façade au
bénéfice de la majorité la raison est
calibrée en effet pour cette majorité
est d'une certaine façon cette
modernisation est un village potemkine
dans les faits elle remplit elle rend
elle renforce la majorité est affaibli
l'opposition j'ai évoqué la modification
de la règle du tourniquet le plus
souvent le président de la commission et
le rapporteur sont issus de la majorité
ce sera ensuite un long tunnel
d'intervention si l'on enchaîne
immédiatement avec les orateurs de la
majorité
nous ne sommes pas dupes le groupe l'est
républicain se ménage des marges de
manoeuvre à des fins qui le concerne en
interne cela doit-il conduire à inscrire
de nouvelles reines qui trahissent
quelque part l'esprit de l'institution
sénatoriales d'un respect du pluralisme
et nos différences même si les
affrontements sans rue parfois nous ne
pensons pas les droits de l'opposition
sont par ailleurs oublié les droits de
l'opposition devrait être plutôt
renforcée notamment en allongeant les
espaces réservés ou en attribuant la
présidence de la commission des finances
à l'opposition cette mesure dépend
uniquement de la bonne volonté du
président du sénat actuellement par
souci d'équité également nous proposons
que les irrecevabilité soit justifié
ainsi qu'un euro datage des amendements
pour que le rapporteur comme cela été
précisées dans le groupe de travail
respectent les délais limite de dépôt
des amendements en commission
enfin nous terminons par des reculs
recul en ce qui concerne le droit de
pétition
la rénovation du 30 pétition est timide
elle est même moins dix ans par rapport
à l'existant aurait eu 102 fait le seul
de signature la trop grande latitude
donné à la conférence des présidents le
recul de
délibération et de la transparence des
décisions cela ne va pas dans le sens
d'une démocratisation
c'est assez curieux puisque en 2019
un autre groupe de travail présidé par
gérard larcher avait formulé des
propositions ambitieuses pour revivifier
le droit de pétition
lorsque emmanuel macron tenter de
relancer sa révision institutionnelle
qui n'aboie chi dung qui n'aboutira
finalement jamais nous avons repris
certaines des dispositions et elles
n'ont pas été acceptées nous proposons
au moins d'abaisser le seuil de
signature et de rendre responsables les
commissions compétentes nous proposons
encore et toujours que les travaux en
commission de manière générale soit
public et retransmis cela nous sommes un
minimum démocratique sur la parité c'est
la cerise sur le mauvais gâteau les
mesures sur la parité c'est de
l'affichage et peu de contraintes avec
un risque celui que les groupes majeurs
que le groupe majoritaire externalise la
parité vers les autres groupes
ce n'est pas parce que il y à une
pratique locale de multiplication des
listes locales des forces de droite qui
affaiblissent la parité en amont qu'il
ne convient pas d'y remédier en aval au
sénat nous proposons ainsi que les
présidences de commissions soit
complètement paritaire ce qui nous
semble assez facile à mettre en oeuvre
vous l'avez compris notre perspective
était démocratique dans les discussions
des correctifs sont utiles mais nous
nous opposons à des mesures qui abaisse
le parlement et qui font le jeu du
pouvoir exécutif et nous proposons et
nous voulions proposer des droits
renforcés pour l'opposition
des pétitions citoyennes mieux
considérés et une parité effective dans
les instances du sénat dans la mesure où
ces propositions n'ont pas exact était
accepté nous ne voterons pas ce texte
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à madame la parole est à présent
oui à madame vanina paoli gage un pardon
je ne voyais pas du groupe les
indépendants pour cinq minutes une fois
la présidente mes chers collègues le
texte que nous examinons constitue l'un
des trois instruments d'une réforme qui
vise à modifier nos méthodes de travail
pendant plusieurs mois une concertation
a été menée à cet effet au sein d'un
groupe de travail dédié 39 propositions
ont été arrêtés
les quatorze qui nécessite une
modification de notre règlement sont
contenues dans cette résolution
elle vise à rendre plus efficace le
travail de notre assemblée et la plupart
d'entre elles sont consensuelles
l'amélioration du suivi des ordonnances
renforce les pouvoirs de contrôle du
parlement
même si leurs membres a tendance à
augmenter significativement au fil des
ans
il s'agit de véhicules législatifs qui
n'ont pas vocation à être validé notre
chambre se dote ainsi des moyens
d'information qui lui permettront
d'exercer sa vigilance à cet égard nous
sommes par ailleurs favorable à ce que
la commission saisie au fond puisse
déclarer irrecevable les amendements
parlementaires qui habiliterait le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
nous devons en effet veiller à exercer
pleinement notre compétence du
législateur pour renforcer encore les
pouvoirs de contrôle du sénat le texte
prévoit notamment de faciliter la
transformation des questions écrites
restée sans réponse en question orale
cette disposition est tout à fait
pertinentes à nos yeux de trop
nombreuses questions restent sans
réponse il est important que le
gouvernement soit contraint de les
apporter afin de rapprocher nos travaux
des préoccupations de la population
la proposition de résolution a également
pour objet d'entériner le système de
pétitions celle qui dépasseront un seuil
de signatures seront systématiquement
examinés par la conférence des
présidents
nous sommes favorables à ce que le sénat
conserve la pleine maîtrise des suites à
donner
à ces pétitions et puissent aussi évoqué
des pétitions qui n'ont pas atteint ce
seuil sans se laisser enfermer de part
et d'autre dans une quelconque
automaticité qui serait inopportune dans
le même objectif de modernisation la
résolution propose de renforcer la
parité au sein du bureau du sénat
nous soutenons cette disposition qui
implique toutefois que nous comptions
plus de femmes dans nos rangs enfin la
proposition de résolution entend
notamment raccourcir la durée des
interventions de dessinateurs de dominos
30 à 2 minutes
au fil des ans l'activité parlementaire
n'a cessé de croître afin de suivre ce
rythme accru la proposition de
résolution vise à accélérer nos débats
en réduisant notre temps de parole nous
convenons du fait que la quantité de
textes que nous avons examinés rend le
travail législatif
de plus en plus difficile cependant nous
nous interrogeons sur le moyen de
résoudre ce problème
le temps du débat ou permet d'alimenter
les réflexions parfois même est souvent
de trouver des accords sa réduction fait
courir un risque à la qualité de nos
travaux en outre il nous apparaît qu'une
telle réduction va à l'encontre de
l'essence même de la fonction du
parlementaire faire entendre la parole
de ceux qui nous ont élus
nous sommes donc très réservée sur ces
dispositions qui nous semblent mettre en
danger l'équilibré existant sans pour
autant produire l'effet attendu d'
accélération significative de nos débats
un autre équilibre doit impérativement
être préservée il s'agit de celui qui
détermine actuellement l'ordre des
prises de parole aujourd'hui afin de ne
pas hiérarchiser la valeur de la parole
des sénateurs l'ordre de passage des
orateurs en discussion générale est
fixée par tirage au sort
le texte de la révolution de la
résolution pardon nous propose de ne
plus renvoyer l'orateur qui appartient
au même groupe que celui du rapporteur
enfin de tourniquets cette disposition
s'inscrit dans une tendance plus large
visant à favoriser dans les prises de
parole les orateurs issus des deux
groupes dont émane quasiment tous les
présidents de commissions et les
rapporteurs
six groupes sur huit ont manifesté leur
hostilité à cette proposition et le
groupe des indépendants ont fait partie
nous considérons que l'ordre des prises
de parole ne doit pas favoriser les
groupes les plus nombreux qui bénéficie
déjà d'un temps proportionnelle à leur
taille est dans la lignée des traditions
du sénat nous devons veiller au respect
de la parole de tous les sénateurs
nous vous proposons donc de voter un
amendement de suppression de la
modification de la règle du tourniquet
chers collègues souvenons nous de ces
mots de camus et la démocratie ce n'est
pas la loi de la majorité
mais la protection de la minorité je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à la présidente
pascale gruny pour le groupe des
républicains pour dix minutes
chers collègues
on n'entend pas mais ça c'est pas moi
20ème la présidente de la commission des
lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues il est bon que notre assemblée
se penchent régulièrement sur son mode
de fonctionnement et ses méthodes de
travail et qu'elle y apporte les
aménagements nécessaires pour mieux
exercer ses missions
le président gérard larcher il y a
toujours été très attentif c'est le sens
de la démarche qu'il a une nouvelle fois
engagé avec la mise en place en fin
d'année dernière d'un groupe de travail
pluraliste dont j'ai eu le grand honneur
d'être le rapporteur je peux témoigner
de la richesse des échanges intervenus
en son sein ils ont abouti à près d'une
quarantaine de propositions dont
certaines peuvent être mises en oeuvre
sur simple décision du bureau de la
conférence des présidents d'autres
nécessitant une modification du
règlement nous les examinons aujourd'hui
avec cette proposition de résolution
j'insisterai sur quelques points qui me
paraissent particulièrement significatif
est le premier concerne les ordonnances
le recours aux ordonnances s'est
notablement accru ces dernières années
et il a pris une ampleur inédite au
cours de cette législature et cela ne
tient pas exclusivement la gestion de la
crise sanitaire et de ses conséquences
il y a là une tendance de fond qui n'est
pas particulièrement relier à des
considérations de technicité ou
d'urgence des sujets on observe en effet
que les délais entre une demande
d'habilitation et la parution de leur
donnant ce sont en moyenne très
supérieurs à ceux constatés pour
l'adoption d'un projet de loi
on a plutôt le sentiment que façon
manque de maturité de certaines réformes
l'exécutif s'est trop souvent à la
facilité d'une habilitation législative
lui laissant du temps pour arrêter ses
choix tout en le dispensant du débat
parlementaire
une procédure qui devrait rester
exceptionnel se banalise ainsi sans
véritable justification
cette dérive est d'autant moins
acceptable que durant toute la durée
d'une habilitation le parlement n'est
plus autorisé à légiférer sur la matière
législative déléguée au sein du groupe
de travail beaucoup de nos collègues ont
souhaité un encadrement plus strict du
recours aux ordonnances dans la
constitution en 2018 en vue de
révision constitutionnelle annoncé un
précédent groupe de travail du sénat
avait d'ailleurs proposé d'inscrire dans
l'article 38 des délais stricts pour la
durée de l'habilitation et celle de la
ratification
en attendant de pouvoir aborder cette
question dans un texte constitutionnel
il est important que le sénat marque sa
volonté de reprendre la main en opérant
un contrôle plus étroit de la
législation délégué d'ores et déjà
conforme et en propositions du groupe de
travail
un tableau de bord des habilitations
accorder des délais fixés par la loi des
ordonnances publiées et des
rectifications a été mis en ligne sur le
site du sénat et une première synthèse à
vocation trimestriels retraçant
l'actualité des ordonnances a été
adressé à tous les sénateurs ces
éléments désormais facilement
accessibles aux sénateurs au groupe
politique et au public constitue une
bonne base pour mieux assurer
l'indispensable de suivi des
habilitations accordé c'est une mission
qui exercent déjà les commissions
permanentes leurs responsabilités en la
matière doit figurer explicitement dans
le règlement avec un rôle spécifique
pour les rapporteurs des textes
législatives comme cela a déjà été
prévue pour l'application des lois
concrètement le groupe de travail a
suggéré que les commissions identifie
des le débat d'habilitation les
ordonnances dans le suivi exige une
vigilance particulière et que le sénat
puisse prendre l'initiative de soumettre
leur ratification à l'examen
parlementaire avec le dépôt et
l'inscription des propositions de loi un
débat en séance de même type que celui
sur l'application des lois pourrait
également être organisée chaque année
afin que le gouvernement soient tenus de
rendre compte régulièrement de l'usaj
fait des habilitations demande et
l'obligation pour le gouvernement de
présenter à la conférence des présidents
au début de chaque session ordinaire un
programme prévisionnel de publication
des ordonnances et d'inscription à
l'ordre du jour des projets de loi de
ratification prévue par l'article 2 de
la proposition de résolution complète le
dispositif
et je pense bien bienvenue que la
commune i la commission les passer au
semestre
aux yeux de notre groupe les
modifications apportées aux règlements
et les autres mesures préconisées par le
groupe de travail permettront des
avancées importantes
de nature assure un meilleur contrôle et
il faut l'espérer
un mieux meilleur usage du recours aux
ordonnances le deuxième volet important
de cette réforme du règlement concerne
les pétitions le droit de pétition
prédit parlement s'inscrit dans une
tradition ancienne
il avait cependant perdu sa traduction
concrète et les dispositions le
concernant dans notre règlement
paraissait largement obsolète on pouvait
s'interroger sur l'intérêt de maintenir
une procédure de ce type les citoyens
les associations les organisations et
groupements d'intérêts dispose
aujourd'hui de bien d'autres moyens de
saisir directement les parlementaires et
de donner écho à leurs démarches dans
les médias sur internet ou sur les
réseaux sociaux
pourtant le droit de pétition près du
parlement fonctionne dans un certain
nombre de démocraties
j'en ai fait moi même l'expérience en
siégeant durant plusieurs années au sein
de la commission des pétitions du
parlement européen
j'ai participé à l'instruction de
questions soulevées par les pétitions
qui lui étaient adressées je me félicite
que le sénat s'engage dans une
rénovation du droit de pétition
l'article 4 de la proposition de
résolution on pose les bases et en fixe
les grands principes
il reviendra au bureau de définir ses
modalités d'exercice notamment les
conditions de recevabilité des pétitions
et les suites qui pourront leur être
données par les instances du sénat et se
partage entre règlement et instructions
générales du bureau apporte la souplesse
nécessaire dans le cas où des
ajustements mériterait d'être apportées
au dispositif à ce sujet des positions
très diverses sont exprimées au sein du
groupe de travail
notre groupe considère que les options
retenues sont équilibrés et ce qu'a
prévu la commission en séparant bien le
le bureau et la conférence des
présidents est aussi bienvenus il est
proposé de maintenir à cent mille
signatures le seuil au delà duquel une
pétition est obligatoirement évoqué en
conférence des présidents
nous avons constaté avec la proposition
de loi sur l'allocation adulte handicapé
que ce seuil peut être atteint si
l'intérêt et le soutien sont réels en
tout état de cause l'article 4 de la
proposition de résolution prévoit que la
conférence des présidents pourra se
saisir de certaines pétitions
quand bien même ce seuil ne serait pas
atteint au vu de leurs intérêts ou du
nombre de signatures
le groupe de travail a également
souhaité mieux identifier parmi les
procédures relevant de l'initiative
législative ou du contrôle les suites
pouvant être réservée aux pétitions
c'est important pour donner à ce droit
un prolongement concret dans nos travaux
pour autant dernier ressort le
nécessaire pouvoir d'appréciation des
instances du sénat sera préservée en
excluant toute automaticité lié à un
seuil de signature la refonte du droit
de pétition telle que prévue par la
proposition de résolution permet au
sénat de se doter d'un outil de dialogue
avec les citoyens modernes simple et
facilement accessible dans le
prolongement de l'expérimentation menée
depuis l'an dernier le groupe l'est
républicain soutien bien entendu les
autres dispositions de cette réforme du
règlement qui améliorent les conditions
d'exercice du contrôle et apporte des
ajustements destiné à mieux utiliser le
temps de séance publique
à ce propos je ne vois pas dans la
modification des temps de parole une
mesure de contrainte mais plutôt un
moyen de mieux organiser nos discussions
dont nous savons qu'elles sont souvent
compris mais en fin de discussion des
textes une présentation concise est en
outre bien souvent plus efficace que la
lecture d'un texte rédigé et l'intérêt
des débats tient aussi à leur vivacité
je terminerai en soutenant l'article 14
de la proposition de résolution qui fixe
un objectif de parité dans la
composition du bureau du sénat
pour chacune des fonctions de
vice-président de questeur et de
secrétaire nous avons constaté en
octobre 2020 que les groupes se sont
organisés pour tendre à cette parité
elle demeure 5
cependant à part faite puisqu'à ce jour
au sénat aucune femme n'a accédé à la
fonction de questeur contraire dans
l'assemblée nationale qui désigne une
femme à ce poste
sans discontinuer depuis 2007
je souhaite que la formulation précise
bien qu un site at il retenu par
l'article 14 permettent à notre
assemblée de franchir cette étape lors
du prochain renouvellement
en conclusion le groupe les républicains
considèrent que cette réforme du
règlement comporte des avancées
importantes notamment sur le contrôle
des ordonnances et des pétitions et
qu'elle apporte des améliorations utiles
au fonctionnement et à l'organisation du
travail de notre assemblée
c'est pourquoi elle votera en faveur de
cette proposition de résolution dans le
texte adopté par la commission des lois
je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente
la parole est à présent madame nathalie
goulet du groupe union centriste pour 4
minutes chers collègues je le préside la
commission des normes adana vice
présidente
je siège depuis 14 ans dans cette maison
et j'ai vu régulièrement la trophy du
débat en séance publique jusqu'à
la caricature du débat la loi de
finances trois minutes pour les
rapporteurs deux minutes par ci deux
minutes par là le débat la loi de
finances est absolument ridicule ne rime
absolument à rien et nous n'arrivons pas
à le rationaliser et à le rendre plus
efficace quand on pense au travail
qu'ils qui résulte de nos rapporteur à
la commission des finances est ce qu'il
en reste en séance publique et sur les 2
minutes 30
je trouve que c'est un peu délicat de
confondre le débat en commission avec
celui en séance publique parce que le
public n'est pas le même c'est le
président de la commission des lois la
séance publique s'adresse à d'autres de
nos collègues qui n'appartiennent pas la
commission saisie au fond et donc s'ils
ont besoin de s'exprimer sur un texte
pour lesquels ils n'ont pas eu toute la
latitude que nous avons dans nos
commission saisie au fond que ce soit la
commission des lois qui est un exemple
bien entendu mais les autres commissions
quand le débat arrive en séance publique
c'est l'ensemble du sénat qui devient ce
qui est saisie du texte pour lesquels il
ya beaucoup d'autres de nos collègues
qui n'appartiennent pas à cette
commission et qui ont envie de
s'exprimer
donc réduire leur temps de parole ne
peut pas être compensée par le temps de
parole qu'ont eu les autres dans la
commission saisie au fond je pense que
là il ya une légère inflexion de la
réflexion qui me semble pas très logique
pour ce qui concerne le pouvoir de
contrôle qui devrait être l'adn de notre
parlement
moi je soutiens qu'il faut une
augmentation des droits de tirage pour
les commissions d'enquêté l'émission
d'information c'est le coeur de notre
métier nous le faisons très bien bon et
nous avons fait de l'excellent travail
enterrés immédiatement après la fin des
commissions et quelques années plus tard
le sujet rejaillit et on se dit parfois
le sénat à travailler là-dessus où il a
travaillé là dessus mais plus personne
ne le sait et donc je pense notamment
aux deux commissions d'enquêté demandée
par le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen sur la fraude fiscale où nous
n'avons jamais pu avoir de suivi alors
qu'elle avait un vrai un vrai sujet et
qui continue à être un vrai sujet il a
fallu se battre pour avoir un groupe de
travail au sein de la commission des
finances ce qui n'est tout à fait pas la
même chose qu'une délégation réservé à
cette question qui montrerait quand même
autrement la modernité du sénat avec une
délégation à la fraude fiscale que à
temps de parole réduit
je pense que là
on montreraient l'exemple à l'assemblée
nationale sur un sujet éminemment
citoyens éminemment important surtout
dans cette période de crise et puis nous
avons eu des commission denquête
absolument formidable chance à celle du
médiator qui a suivi celle du vioxx où
nous avons émis un certain nombre de
préconisations sur la sécurité sanitaire
à chaque fois qu'on a un débat sur la
sécurité sanitaire
on revient aux préconisations qui ont
été faites par là par la commission donc
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir aux moyens d'avoir un suivi de
notre travail plutôt que de que de
l'enterrer et puis il ya sûrement
beaucoup d'autres commission denquête
qui mériterait d'avoir un processus de
suivi et je pense que c'est vers ça
qu'il faut tendre vers ça qu'il faut
réfléchir
et puis moi j'aurais pratiquement
terminée avec avec mon temps de parole
pour vous dire qu'il faut être deux pour
le jeu pour danser le tango
parce que l'ordre du jour partagé qui en
2008 était une très bonne idée sur le
papier devient un problème totalement
inextricable canton l'appliquent de
façon rigoureuse aujourd'hui en séance
cet ordre du jour partagé nounou
saucissonne les débats et les rendent
parfois complètement inintelligible
puisque des débats très importants sont
interrompus par des débats de contrôle
ou des débats d'initiative parlementaire
sans pouvoir être plus souple sur sur
l'ordre du jour donc moi je pense que le
la réflexion doit se poursuivre sur une
modernisation évidemment de notre
travail mais pas au détriment de la
séance publique pas au détriment des
groupes minoritaires ni des gens
minoritaire au sein de leur groupe
qu'ils sont deux fois minoritaires voyez
vous voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements et que j'attende l issue
de ces amendements pour me prononcer sur
le vote
merci chers collègues
la parole est enfin monsieur stéphane le
rudulier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
pour une durée de 4 minutes cyr collègue
jaime à damas la présidente
la vice président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
alors je ne vais pas revenir points un
point sur les nombreuses modifications
de notre règlement a porté à travers
cette proposition de résolution
modifications d'ailleurs qui ont été
brillamment exposé par madame la
rapporteur du groupe de travail et
monsieur le président de la commission
mais je souhaitais m'a retardé quelques
instants avec vous tout particulièrement
sur le phénomène inquiétant pour notre
démocratie parlementaire et dont le
texte en examen aujourd'hui essaient
d'en maîtriser les écueils
je vais évoquer avec vous ce recours
parfois abusif aux ordonnances à travers
l'article 38 de notre loi fondamentale
car force est de reconnaître que le
gouvernement par ordonnance est devenue
au fil de ces dernières années
une marque de fabrique de l'exécutif
nous en sommes à 264 ordonnance
en quatre ans les chemins fort que le
record détenu par le président hollande
de 273 ordonnance soit très vite battu
dans les prochaines semaines
au point même que nous avons de plus en
plus la désagréable sensation que la loi
n'apparaît plus comme le processus
normal de l'hésitation
en somme le caractère exceptionnel que
devait revêtir cette procédure dans
l'esprit initial de la vème république
s'est quelque peu étiolé
les ordonnances sont devenus au cours
des décennies un moyen une manière de
contourner le parlement de confisquer le
pouvoir législatif au parlement et c'est
d'autant plus inquiétant car le régime
juridique de ces ordonnances a été
bouleversé par un revirement récent de
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel
dorénavant les ordonnances dont le
projet de ratification a été déposée
mais n'ont examiné par les deux chambres
dans les délais d'habilitation imparti
acquiert la force de la loi
cela m'est cher collègue vient renforcer
une nouvelle fois la dépossession du
pouvoir parlementaire
il suffit dès lors à l'exécutif de
déposer ses projets de ratification sur
le bureau de l'assemblée nationale qui
n'aura qu'à l'ére lisez en attendant
l'expiration du délai d'habilitation
afin d'éviter tout examen par nos deux
chambres alors six personnes au cours
des majorités qui se sont succédé depuis
la naissance de la vème république n'a
proposé d'abroger ce fameux article 38
de notre assemblée de notre loi
fondamentale c'est qu'il a forcément son
utilité notamment en cas d'urgence avec
un argument avancé la célérité de la
procédure
le recours aux ordonnances serait donc
un outil de gestion du temps normatif
mais cet argument mis en avant est tout
de même grandement à relativiser
savez vous que le délai moyen pour
prendre l'ordonance une fois la loi
donnant l'habitation promulguée est
d'environ 450 jours contre 177 jours en
moyenne pour la fabrique de la loi alors
pour retrouver une forme d'équilibré des
pouvoirs chère à montesquieu il était
urgent d'agir
c'est ce premier pas que l'on vous
propose avec un outil de suivi des
déchets permettant de retracer des
habilitations accorder les délais fixés
par la loi
les ordonnances publiées ainsi que
l'état des ratifications et renforcer
ainsi notre rôle de contrôle je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est un cyclo je vous propose de
passer à la discussion du texte de la
commission
article premier que je mets aux voix qui
et pour qui s'abstient qui est contre il
est adopté
j'aime et je vois l'article 2 qui pour
qui s'abstient qui est contre il est
adopté
article 3 qui votent pour contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté de façon à
l'article 4 rouges et trois amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune avec l'amendement numéro sept
présentés par monsieur kerrouche merci
madame la présidente
il ya un choix à faire en matière de
démocratisation où on donne l'apparence
de la démocratisation ou on fait en
sorte que celle ci soit effective nous
considérons que avec les mesures que
nous prenons actuellement nous allons
plutôt vers un une apparence de
démocratisation et non pas une
opérationnalisation de celle ci je ne
pense pas qu'il faille et nous ne
pensons pas qu'il faille douter de la
capacité des citoyens à sur des sujets
particuliers tentés de prendre la parole
pour faire justement en sorte que cette
parole accèdent aux finales au parlement
et faire en sorte que d'une certaine
façon certaines thématiques soient
inscrits sur l'agenda législatif
bien entendu on vous proposant
d'abaisser ce seuil il n'en demeure pas
moins que il y a toujours une
possibilité ensuite d'opérer un contrôle
dans la commission conserver sur la
recevabilité ou pas de là
de la pétition il nous semble que cette
ce changement de rythme de la de la
pétition nous permettrait de faire en
sorte d'avoir un outil qui soit encore
une fois réellement utilisable et non
pas celui que nous allons nous avons
actuellement et que nous allons
pérenniser puisque avec la limite des
formules signature ça a été dit plus
avant il y a eu à ma connaissance une
seule pétition qui a dépassé ce seuil
ça veut bien dire qu'il est largement
inaccessible je comprends la défiance
que l'on peut avoir par rapport à
certaines minorités actives
il n'en demeure pas moins encore une
fois qu'il y aura l'attitude de contrôle
après mai soit nous nous ouvrons au
citoyen soit nous ne faisons pas et on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas rester dans
la demi mesure que nous connaissons
actuellement et que visiblement vous
souhaité reconduire
d'où cette proposition d'abaissement du
seuil
en ce qui concerne les pétitions merci
chers collègues je demande l'avis du
deux autres amendements pardon je
croyais si le temps de redémarrer
l'amendement 35 qui est présentée par
monsieur gontard oui merci madame la
présidente
cet amendement a pour objet également de
préciser notre mécanisme de pétition
citoyenne
le système actuel est peu satisfaisant
nous proposons une inscription
automatique à l'ordre du jour notre
assemblée dans un délai de trois mois de
tout pétition ayant atteint le nombre
suffisant de signatures sur le site du
sénat
on échange et cette automaticité nous
relevons ce seuil ce seuil nécessaire
cette inscription automatique à l'ordre
du jour assure et aux citoyennes et
citoyens droit de pétition renforcer ce
n'est pas ainsi occasionnée rapprocher
d'autres institutions répondant à leurs
aspirations et un renouveau démocratique
le système actuel est peu lisible nous
deux nous devons de ne pas trahir la
confiance de lecteurs par de fausses
promesses en faisant miroiter la
suppression de leur pétition à l'ordre
du jour lorsque celle ci est en réalité
filtré dans le passage obligatoire en
conférence des présidents
bien que réunir des milliers de
signatures soit coûteux et chronophage
un manque de certains
thud entoure encore aujourd'hui l'issue
d'une pétition dont l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour n'est donc donc qu'à en
aucun cas assuré nous proposer un sens
par cet amendement la suppression de ce
mécanisme louer et des incitatifs et
nous souhaitons nous inscrire dans la
logique d'une démocratie plus
collaborative notre attachement aux
principes de démocratie représentative
nous pousse en effet nous satisfaire
pleinement de propositions émises par
nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens et
leur offrir cette niche à notre heure du
jour
charge à nous élus du peuple de débattre
et de trancher nous conservons en fin de
compte le dernier mot pour conclure nous
sommes également naturellement en accord
avec les propositions celle qui vient
d'être est exposée par notre collègue
socialiste et puis par les propositions
communistes nous avons aussi assis opté
pour une profession plus d'eux qu'ils
soient plus de compromis plus propice à
favoriser un accord sur ce que ce sujet
merci merci chers collègues la
proposition communiste va arriver par
l'amendement 37 présentait pas la
présidente est fait mais si madame la
présidente je crois l'avoir dit dans la
discussion générale nous sommes
favorables au développement du droit de
pétition toutefois il ne sommes qu il
faudrait quand même examiner les
conditions de la mise en oeuvre de ce
droit pour savoir en fait si la réalité
des propositions est conforme à la
volonté qui est affiché et avant toute
chose il est regrettable d'examiner
aujourd'hui cette proposition sans avoir
l'ensemble des éléments c'est à dire les
conditions de recevabilité décidé
ailleurs au sein du bureau du sénat
le champ du droit de pétition pose
problème et suscite débats comme à un
autre biais niveau pose débat aussi la
question du référendum
pourquoi par exemple exclure du champ du
droit de pétition les questions
constitutionnelles et donc souvent
institutionnel mais surtout surtout de
regrettons fortement que la proposition
de résolution confié à la conférence des
présidents et donc à la majorité
sénatoriale
mais ce serait de toute façon la même
chose si la décision revenait au niveau
de la commission c'est donc toujours la
majorité qui
in fine et déciderait ce filtre majorité
apparaît pleinement conditionné avec
l'idée d'ouverture démocratique
découlant du droit de pétition cela
pourrait même devenir une forme nouvelle
d'initiative majoritaire puisque la
conférence des présidents
sa majorité pour a repêché une pétition
n'ayant pas atteint le nombre de
signatures requises et c'est pourquoi
nous proposons avec cet amendement
d'inverser la règle en disposant qu'une
peau d'une pétition ne pourra être
écartée que si une forme quasi totale de
consensus s'établit en ce sens merci
chers collègues je nomme l'avis du
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
le président l'avis de la commission est
défavorable sur les trois amendements
je rappelle le principe qui est proposée
par le présent marché pour une pétition
dont le nombre est fixé par le bureau
pour en fixer sa recevabilité
d'abord lorsque ce seuil est atteint
automatiquement on a parlé de 100 mille
pétitionnaires automatiquement la
pétition est renvoyé à la conférence des
présidents qui décide de la suite à
donner
en dessous il n'y a pas de caractère
automatique
en revanche la proposition prévoit que
s'il ya un intérêt
la conférence des présidents peut
éventuellement se saisir de cette
pétition et éventuellement de lui donner
une suite favorable
c'est le principe qui a été adopté
proposé en tous les cas par le président
larcher avec cet objectif de donner à la
conférence des présidents
la liberté totale de décider les trois
amendements qui sont proposés on
poursuivre tous trois objectifs 1 on
propose trois moyens différents le
premier celui de monsieur kerrouche
c'est de fixer un seuil dans le
règlement alors que nous l'avons décidé
qui serait fixée par le bureau de fixer
ce seuil à 50 mille pétitionnaires est
systématiquement de renvoyer à la
conférence des présidents qui décidera
de la suite donc un seuil très bas c'est
un choix le deuxième choix
c'est le choix de notre collègue me
gontard qui dit on fixe à 300 mille le
nombre de pétitionnaires et dès lors que
ce nombre est atteint
il est automatiquement décidé de
renvoyer d'organiser le débat nécessaire
avec ce caractère automatique
et puis la troisième proposition de
notre collègue madame assassi consiste à
dire il faut que la conférence des
présidents est finalement une sorte de
minorités 20 mais jo a été qualifiée des
trois cinquièmes qui permettrait de
refuser 4/5 pardon de rares excuses moi
lors de refuser la suite des répétitions
ça n'est pas le choix qui est proposée
par dans la résolution par le président
du sénat issu des débats qui sont tenues
pendant le mois de décembre jusqu'au
mois de mars dernier la commission des
lois a émis un avis défavorable tout en
confirmant l'idée qu'il fallait laisser
la liberté à conférence des présidents
de pouvoir faire les choses madame bruni
maintenant la présidente greny pour
explication de vote
oui merci beaucoup même le président tu
es juste donné l'éclairage sur la
pétition que nous avons prises sur
l'allocation adulte handicapé au moment
où on fait tout et on l'a examiné à la
conférence des présidents elle était
entre soixante et soixante soixante dix
mille signatures et on a bien décidé à
ce moment là avec bien entendu un
entrain échange qui a été fait avec la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pour la prendre
donc c'est bien le bon exemple que ça
n'avait pas atteint les 100 nil mais que
le sujet était était essentielle et
qu'il fallait la prendre ça a été décidé
en conférence des présidents donc c'est
le bon exemple en fait c'est que la
conférence elle peut déroger tout à fait
en fait au seuil qu'on a indiqué merci
chers collègues je mets donc on voit la
maman numéro 70 avec un avis défavorable
qui votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée même
vote pour le 35ème vote même voix pour
le 30 sept
ils ne sont donc pas adoptée je mets aux
voix l'article 4 qui votent pour contre
qui s'abstient il est donc adopté
article additionnel avant l'article 5
l'amendement 15 présentée par monsieur
kerrouche
merci madame la présidente
l'article 39 2 2 du règlement de
l'assemblée nationale stipule que ne
peut être élu à la présidence de la
commission des finances qu'un député qui
appartient au groupe s'étant déclarés
d'opposition nous proposons avec cet
amendement de consacrer dans notre
règlement usages qui prévaut depuis 2007
donc à l'assemblée nationale et depuis
2011 au sénat qui veut que en vertu de
cette décision le président de la
commission des finances appartient à un
membre de l'opposition dans l'état
actuel des choses cette disposition au
sénat ne tient qu'à la bonne qu'à la
bonne volonté du président qu'il faut
remarquer et remercié pour autant il est
sans doute nécessaire désormais de faire
comme à l'assemblée nationale et de
l'inscrire dans notre règlement
je termine en disant que vous savez que
cette procédure qui en fait des rives
d'une proposition de nicolas sarkozy
cette procédure est de plus en plus
généralisé au sein de multiples
institutions et franchement il n'est pas
très compréhensible qu'elle ne soit pas
inscrite dans notre règlement et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose puisque
ça me vient tous assez au courant du
fait que majorité et opposition
ça peut être amené à évoluer dans le
temps il monsieur rappaz retard c'est un
avis défavorable sur cet amendement
était rendu par la commission
j'en donne l'explication le principe de
la présidence de la commission des
finances donné aux groupes d'opposition
est une initiative qui date de 2007
c'est le président poncelet à l'époque
puis ensuite le président larcher a
continué puis le président bayle à
respecter l'engagement de ses
prédécesseurs évidemment le drian
larcher a continué de respecter ses
engagements cela fait 14 ans que nous
fonctionnons de cette manière là et
c'est devenu d'évidence personne ne
songe aujourd'hui à remettre en cause ce
dispositif est donc on a considéré en
tous les cas c'est ce qu'a soutenu
groupe ça n'a pas été débattue ce faire
de ma part pendant le groupe de travail
je pars sur le contrôle de l'inde
ni mais en toute hypothèse on a
considéré qu'il fallait garder cet usage
qui relevait d'un bon comportement dans
le fonctionnement de notre institution
c'est la raison pour laquelle la vie
était défavorable
merci messieurs les rouges sur le
président de la commission sur la porter
aux herbes à walhain scripta manent suis
désolé mais encore une fois ce qui est
il vaut mieux écrire les choses que
simplement procéder d'une coutume la
caractéristique de la coutume c'est
endroits et notamment en droit
constitutionnel qu'elle se maintient
dans le temps mais elle n'est pas à
l'abri de modifications qui peuvent être
unilatérale si vous pensez qu'il est
automatique et que l'on doit forcément
respecter le fait est que personne ne
saurait remettre en cause cette règle
alors franchement franchement je ne
comprends absolument pas ce qui vous
empêche de le mettre dans le règlement
parce que sinon sinon on peut aussi
poser quand même que vous avez un
certain doute sur sa pérennité
le président faire je voulais madame la
présidente félicité le président
françois noël buffet parce qu'il a
complètement défendu et très bien
l'amendement de monsieur qui rouge je
crois qu'on aurait pu mettre son
intervention comme exposé des motifs à
l'amendement de monsieur et rouge
puisqu'il a dit tout le bien qu'il
pensait de cette pratique qu'il ne songe
nullement remettre en cause par
conséquent il me semble que le propos de
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois devrait nous conduire adopté à
une très large majorité vers à
l'unanimité l'amendement de ce thé rouge
merci cher collègue monsieur président
karoutchi
je le comprends l'amendement mais en
réalité nous ne sommes pas une
institution administrative et
personnellement j'ai été président de la
commission des finances de la région ile
de france quand jean paul huchon en
était le président donc j'étais
l'opposant si je puis dire et valérie
pécresse a continué et c'est aujourd'hui
une élue socialiste que vous connaissez
bien que présidente de la commission des
finances
mais nous sommes des assemblées
politiques avec des équilibres
politiques
donc moi je souhaite franchement qu'on
reste sur cette notion d'un président
appartenant à l'opposition mais rien ni
personne ne sait ce que sera l'assemblée
nationale ce que sera le sénat dans dix
ans et nous sommes dans l'obligation de
nous dire que tant que nous sommes dans
un système où avec une composition
d'assemblée août sénat respectant les
règles et c'est à ça se fera de manière
naturelle
le jour où vous n'avez plus à il faut
pas se retrouver dans quelque chose qui
s'imposerait et qui ne serait pas
naturellement accepté par tout le monde
merci président je donne la parole
maintenant la présidente à ça si oui
merci madame la présidente j'avoue que
je ne comprends pas effectivement le
fait que d'autres commission rejette cet
abandon j'entends les arguments de
monsieur karoutchi est effectivement
dans d'autres collectivités institutions
il y a cet accord en fait entre
l'opposition et la majorité notamment
sur la présidence et sur la sur les
commissions des finances
mais moi j'attire votre attention moi
vous fonctionnez comme si l'opposition
était toujours celle d'aujourd'hui
et comme si la majorité serait toujours
celle d'aujourd'hui
or je ne l'espère pas pour être honnête
sauf que nous soyons dans la majorité
bien évidemment mais il peut se passer
des choses dans d'autres pays
et oui et il s'en passe effectivement et
des choses qui pourraient nuire à la
démocratie en tout cas c'est mon point
de vue donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux
inscrire la proposition qui est faite
par nos collègues socialistes dans le
règlement plutôt que de se contenter de
ce qui existe depuis des années mais qui
pourrait être bouleversé malheureusement
dans les années pour ne pas dire les
mois à venir
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement numéro 15 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée jeu mais se voit l'article 5
qui va pour contre abstentions il est
adopté un moment sur l'article 6
l'amendement numéro 8 présentée par
monsieur kerrouche oui madame la
présidente
cet amendement vise à prévoir qu'une
demande de création d'une commission
d'enquêté va donner systématiquement
lieu à un affichage et une notification
gouvernement présidents trouver
président de commission en dehors des
jours où le cdh un tiers séance merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
défavorable de la commission nous
souhaitons que le président du sénat
puis je lui même porté d'accord le
désaccord sur la création de cette
commission d'enquêté qu'il ne soit pas
du caractère automatique
je mets donc aux voix cents amendements
numéro 8 avec un avis défavorable qui
votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
je me revois l'article 6 qui votent pour
contre attention il est adopté un
amendement sur l'article 7 numéro 34
représentée par monsieur gontard oui
merci mme la présidente
cet amendement a pour objet de le
renforcement des droits de l'opposition
cher à la haute assemblée
il prévoit la présence d'au moins un
membre de chaque groupe d'opposition au
sein de tous les groupes de travail
lancés en notre sein c'est généralement
le cas mais certaines exceptions récente
invite à préciser la chose dans notre
règlement
en effet il n'est pas envisageable
ignorer la pluralité politique en
n'incluant pas certains groupes
parlementaires dans les groupes de
travail
on peut par exemple relevé l'exclusion
certains groupes dont celui juge j'ai
l'honneur de présider
plusieurs doutent votre travail de la
commission des affaires économiques
après la constitution de plusieurs
groupes de travail de suivi
foulées du renouvellement sénatorial
groupe s'est trouvé mis à la marge
notamment du groupe de suivi et galim du
groupe de travail nouvelle forme de
commerce du groupe de travail
agriculture en situation de détresse ou
encore du groupe de travail assurance
récolte
aucun groupe n'a donc pas pu participer
nous en sommes émus sans succès et on
nous a rétorqué que la faiblesse
numéraire de ces groupes ne permet pas
de nous accorder une place il convient
donc de garantir par le biais de cet
amendement que ces situations ne se
reproduisent plus et que la
représentation des groupes d'opposition
dans le travail parlementaire soit
respecté en toutes circonstances merci
président monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis s'il vous plaît même le président
en fait je me tourne la prison tard pour
lui dire que son amendement il satisfait
puisque lui demandent de le retirer à
défaut ce sera un avis défavorable
pourquoi je dis ça parce que votre
demande est satisfaite pour les
commissions d enquête de l ordonnance de
58 d'ailleurs impose que la composition
assure la représentation proportionnelle
des groupes politiques
c'est aussi le cas pour les missions
d'information et ceci en application de
l'article 21 de ce règlement et de
l'article 7 de la présente proposition
de résolution pour ce qui concerne les
groupes de travail des commissions
l'usagé veut que soit nommé un binôme
rapporteur majorité opposition et
naturellement les auditions sont
ouvertes à l'ensemble des commissaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
considère que à la commission considère
que votre demande est satisfaite et donc
c'est un retrait si vous acceptez à
défaut ce sera un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur me fais
président vous retirer vous maintenant
non je maintiens parce que effectivement
sur les missions d'information ou sur
les commissions d'enquêté on est on est
d'accord mais sur les groupes de travail
tels qu'ils ont été constitués les
exemples que j'ai donné c'est vrai qu'à
pas cette représentation là et je pense
que c'est mieux du coup de l'inscrire
merci jamais donc aux voix cet
amendement avec un avis défavorable qui
votent pour contre l'abstention il n'est
pas adapté je mets donc au bout à
l'article 7 qui votent pour contre
abstentions l'article 7 est adoptée nous
passons à l'article additionnel après
l'article cet amendement numéro 4
présenté par madame boulet la présidente
monsieur président de la commission des
lois rapporteur il s'agit simplement de
remplacer le mot ou par le mot et c'est
à dire d'autoriser chaque groupe
politique à avoir un droit de tirage par
an pour une commission denquête et une
mission d'information
ça répond bien à l'objectif de la
proposition que nous étudions sur le
renforcement du contrôle et le
renforcement des droits du sénat j'ai
pas beaucoup d'illusions parce qu'il
paraît que ça coûte cher mais je
voudrais l'occasion cet amendement
puisque j'ai un peu de temps rendre
hommage à nos administrateurs qui nous
assiste dans ses missions donc dans ces
commissions d'enquêté dans ses missions
d'information
et comme tout au long de notre travail
et qui sont tout à fait formidable en
tous les cas j'espère que la commission
rendra un avis favorable sur cet
amendement de bon sens
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur là c'est la très chère
collègue vrai que votre espoir est mince
est-ce qu'elle l'avait défavorable est
pas défavorable par principe
naturellement mais parce que dans le
cadre du groupe de travail a été relevé
à plusieurs reprises la multiplication
des missions de contrôle et leur
importance imaginez qu'il y en a eu 120
récemment qu'ils ont été cumulées sur
l'année dernière donc sur 2000 2020 120
groupes de travail mission de contrôle
de toute nature et tout le monde en a
déploré le nombre trop important donc si
on veut rester dans des proportions
correct
l'objectif c'est de conserver le droit
constant c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a émis un avis défavorable
donc soit vous le retirez soit ce sera
un vidéogramme
chers collègues vous retirer vous
maintenant
je vais me retirer mais c'est quand même
pas tout à fait la même chose un groupe
de travail ou une mission flash une
commission une commission denquête ou
une mission d'information c'est ni le
même périmètre ni les mêmes objectifs ni
les mêmes moyens
je regrette cette position je vais
retirer cet amendement
merci chers collègues amendant 30 et 31
n'ont soutenu l'amendement 6 rectifiée
présentée par madame boulet ah oui alors
ça c'est une c'est un sujet extrêmement
important parce que dans le cas des
commission denquête nous avons parfois
eu des sujets importants et notamment
certains certaines personnes
auditionnées on violait purement et
simplement le serment de dire la vérité
rien que la vérité toute la vérité qu'il
avait prononcé lors des auditions et
donc je propose quand le cas du
règlement et donc dans le cadre de la
logique de de plus de pouvoirs de
contrôle du sénat je propose que les le
président et le rapporteur puisse
décider eux des poursuites pour faux
témoignage ce qui me semble extrêmement
important parce que il ya une réactivité
il ya une connaissance du dossier il ya
une connaissance de la commission
denquête ça c'est la première chose et
puis dans l'hypothèse où la commission
aurait cessé ses travaux c'est-à-dire
dans le nez les faits révélés aurait été
postérieure au dépôt du rapport ça
resterait le président et le rapporteur
dans l'hypothèse où les faits révélés
serait postérieur un renouvellement du
sénat dans ces cas là c'est
appartiendrait où il appartiendrait au
bureau du sénat d'engager des poursuites
pour faux témoignage merci chers
collègues mais c'est le rapporteur votre
avis s'il vous plaît même le président
c'est un avis défavorable
d'abord parce que la proposition qui est
faite par notre collègue est contraire
aux discussions l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 relative
au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires qui prévoit que les
poursuites notamment en cas de faux
témoignages et je cite sont engagés à la
requête du président de la commission ou
lorsque le rapport de la commission a
été publié
par le pardon par le bureau de
l'assemblée
donc soit la commission d' enquête se
déroule et le président peut engager les
poursuites en tous les cas saisir
informé le programme public soit la
commission d' enquête est terminée et
c'était quelqu'un le bureau de
l'assemblée
donc pour nous le bureau du sénat bien
évidemment qu'ils puissent saisir ou
signaler la difficulté où l'infraction
au procureur de la république
en aucun cas ce n'est le bureau de la
commission même qui doit le faire raison
pour laquelle un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur jamais donc
qu'on voit cet amendement 6 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée je mets aux voix
l'article 8 qui votent pour contre
abstentions l'article 8 et adopté
article additionnel après l'article de
8g deux amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
le premier le numéro 39 présenté par la
présidente à ça si oui merci madame la
présidente nous réitérons ici une
proposition de bon sens constitutionnel
si la constitution donne la possibilité
à des groupes minoritaires ou
d'opposition d'inscrire des propositions
de loi dans le cas d'un espace réservé
il apparaît donc logique que le
rapporteur ou la rapporteure re puisse
être issu du gouffre qui a demandé
l'exercice de cette prérogative
constitutionnelle
plusieurs commissions dans la pratique
applique ce raisonnement et je n'ai
qu'une question pourquoi la majorité
s'arc boutent elle sur cette question
alors que de toute façon elle garde le
moyen est ce la 1e nous le contestons
pas d'adopter ou de rejeter ces textes
merci présidente a maintenant numéro 16
présentée par monsieur que rouge je ne
vais pas madame la présidente répéter ce
que dit la présidente à ça si nous ne
comprenons pas pourquoi n'y a pas une
codification de cette pratique sachant
que elles existent au sein de certaines
commissions
il s'agirait de la généraliser sachant
que personne
ne conteste la latitude ultime de la
majorité s'agissant du vote si cher
collègue monsieur rapporteur votre avis
sur les deux amants nous voyons c'est un
avis défavorable pour les deux
amendements car l'objectif pour les
commissions est de ne pas désigner un
rapporteur qui de fait sera battu
régulièrement dans la commission au banc
sur un texte qui a peu de chances
d'arriver au bout en revanche nouvelles
des présidents que veille à ce que un
texte susceptible de pouvoir prospérer
en séance puis c'est effectivement à ce
moment là confié à un collègue qui est
appuyé appartient au même groupe que
l'auteur de la proposition
donc on ne veut pas de régime fin le
souhait de ne pas avoir de rigidité
avoir un système qui soit qui restent
adaptées
je rappelle tout de même que les
commissions ne modifie pas les textes
issus de ppl sans l'accord de l'auteur
de de la ppl c'est ce qu'on appelle
entre nous le gentlemen agreement et
nous comptons rester où nous souhaitons
rester sur ce dispositif là cette
manière de faire merci monsieur le
rapporteur je mets donc aux voix ces
deux amendements
le numéro 39 avec un avis défavorable
qui votent pour contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée même vote pour le cese
ne sont pas adopté deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune et
du même auteur monsieur kerrouche est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter le 17 et
le 19
merci
c'est la présidente à un amendement tout
simple nous nous souhaitons que la
publicité des commissions soit de droit
et non pas l'exception comme c'est comme
c'est actuellement
ça nous semble la moindre des choses en
matière de fonctionnement démocratique
17 et 19 donc monsieur le rapporteur est
ce que vous pouvez nous donner votre
avis sur ces deux amendements
c'est un avis défavorable pour les deux
amendements pour le premier vous
demander à ce que systématiquement les
commissions soient filmés en réalité et
de caractère public alors que c'est
aujourd'hui d'exception nos commissions
se réunissent à huis clos et
éventuellement naturellement les
autorisant la diffusion
c'est le cas lorsque nous faisons des
auditions un principalement ou des
commissions ou dans lequel nous avons
des tables des tables rondes
auquel cas nous les rendons public mais
c'est les responsables des commissions
qu'il le décide
et puis enfin sur le deuxième point qui
est la correction éventuelle d'un compte
rendu de commissions vous avez la
possibilité aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire
corriger le compte rendu d'une
commission si vous estimez que il ya une
rédaction qui ne correspond pas
exactement à ce que vous souhaitiez dire
tout cas sans changer le fond ni le sens
il ya aucune difficulté pour ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur ces deux
annonces d'un avis défavorable sur merci
mais cette terre rouge pour explication
de vote sur l'amendement 19 sur le
président vous avez raison sur la
plupart de l'amendement n'est pas en ce
qui concerne les commissions mixtes
paritaires
il n'est pas possible d'avoir des
corrections et c'est un souci je le dis
j'ai été confronté déjà c'est un
problème d'où l'amendement je vous
remercie chers collègues je mets donc
qu'on voit ces deux amendements 17 et 19
qui votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptées la
maman numéro 13 ème siècle et rouge et
madame la présidente je rappelle qu'au
départ ce texte la révision de notre
règlement
procédez de la volonté de tenir compte
de la période que nous avons traversée
de la période de la crise sanitaire et
donc de la nécessité parfois d'adapter
notre notre fonctionnement c'est ce que
nous proposons ici s'agissant des
réunions de commissions
si elles doivent se tenir en
visioconférence il nous semble tout à
fait possible de faire un vote corne
c'est nécessaire par appel nominal qui
n'appelle aucune difficulté en ce qui
concerne la sincérité du vote
ça se pratique dans les assemblées
délibérantes des collectivités
territoriales
c'est une mesure exceptionnelle en cas
exceptionnel que nous avons d'ores et
déjà nous avons déjà vécu et expérimenté
cher collègue monsieur rapporte à votre
avis un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement il a été indiqué depuis le
départ que dans la situation de crise
que nous traversions et dans
l'organisation de nos débats il n'y
aurait pas de vote à distance que sa foi
céderait de façon classique par
procuration je rappelle que le président
du sénat a toujours voulu et défendu
l'interdiction en tous les cas le refus
exactement du parlement virtuel donc si
on accepte ces dispositions on
s'engagerait de ce point de vue là sur
cette voie là ce qui n'était pas
souhaitable puisque d'ailleurs en
affaire fait l'objet d'une discussion
particulière à l'occasion de nos débats
mais qui n'est pas partagée entre
leucate donc l'avis défavorable
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement numéro 13 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission qui votent
pour contre abstentions il n'est donc
pas adoptée
là maintenant 27 rectifié monsieur les
rouges
merci à la présidente je vais serrer
essayer de synthétiser cet amendement
dans le cadre du groupe de travail
nous avons évoqué cette possibilité d'un
débat d'un débat de contrôle en
commission je sais que la présidente
gruny y travaillent sur le sujet du
moins puisque le président du sénat
semblait ouvert à cette proposition la
perspective était simplement à travers
cet amendement de mettre en musique la
façon dont pourrait se dérouler un débat
de contrôle en commission sur le modèle
donc de la législation en commission
avec la possibilité d'inscrire ensuite à
l'ordre du jour une proposition de
résolution sur la base de du travail
réalisé pendant ces débats en commission
qui serait plus interactif et sans doute
plus satisfaisant que les débats de
contrôle que nous avons actuelle merci
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis même
si nous reconnaissons avance puisque
vous allez vous avez indiqué que tout
était défavorable pas tout est vrai
qu'il ya des choses positives
en la circonstance cela reviendrait par
exemple avant le débat que nous avons
eues avant notre séance débat précédent
à la voir en commission l'idée c'est
qu'en réalité en commission les
présidents
quels qu'ils soient peuvent convoquer
évidemment elles le font souvent les
ministres toute autre personne et
organise ce type de débat de contrôle et
ça se fait de surcroît sans limite de
temps pour le coup si on en discute et
donc les choses se passent assez bien
donc l'avis est défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur jamais
madame à ça si oui merci même après je
veux dire que mon groupe ne votera pas
cette cet amendement comme vous le savez
nous sommes pour notre part opposée à la
législation à l'examen des textes en
commission les enlève même si pour être
sincère je n'utilise pas très souvent
mon droit de veto pour que cela ne se
produise pas donc par cohérence mais pas
que par cohérence je suis opposé à la
proposition qui est faite par nos
collègues socialistes et je reprendrai
un peu
un élément du de la discussion générale
et notamment ce qu'a dit madame boulet
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que si nous
procédons par législation en commission
sur des projets de loi
si nos débats de contrôles ont lieu
aussi en commission sincèrement
sincèrement à quoi va servir à terme la
séance publique
merci présidente je donne la parole
maintenant au président karoutchi pour
explication de vote la présidente
moi je comprends l'amendement parce que
je suis de ceux qui considèrent que nos
débats de contrôle
avec ce système à 15 question de minutes
et tout ça n'intéresse que ceux qui
viennent aux questions en général il ya
à peu près pas plus
niamey - parce qu'au fur et à mesure
qu'on pose des questions on s'en va donc
franchement c'est des débats pour pas
grand monde mais en vérité c'est le
système lui-même qui font remettre en
cause et qu'il faut changer modifier
dans notre système de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement c'est pas le
fait que vous transférez ce système en
commission qui le rend meilleur je
dirais même pardon aux dépositaires
l'amendement que quand vous dites que
tout sénateur peut intervenir autant de
fois qu'il le souhaite
2 minutes 30 ça va rendre ces séances
insupportable
donc franchement réfléchissons un autre
mode de contrôle mais sûrement pas en
transférant le problème chez les autres
merci chers collègues je mets donc aux
voix cet amendement 27 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 21 monsieur clés rouge
donc cet amendement vient s'ajuster sur
l'article 29 bis du règlement qui
prévoit que la conférence des présidents
peut inscrire à l'ordre du jour un débat
d'initiative sénatoriale à la demande
d'un groupe politique d'une commission
de la commission des affaires
européennes ou de lait d'une délégation
notre amendement propose qu'au début de
chaque session ordinaire
la conférence des présidents fixe les
règles et les critères qui encadrent le
choix d'aider pas de contrôle afin
d'assurer un traitement équitable entre
les différents groupes politiques
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur
l'amendement lui même est satisfait en
réalité puisque notre collègue vient de
rappeler les entrées justement les
dispositions de l'alinéa 7 de l'article
29 bis que vous souhaitez modifier la
conférence des présidents
vous l'avez dit est en capacité de
pouvoir discuter de l'ordre du jour de
tout débat d'initiative sénatoriales en
général les demandes des groupes sont
pract en pratique
j'ai pas vérifié totalement totalement
satisfaite par la conférence des
présidents
dans ces conditions là je considère
votre demande est satisfaite donc c'est
soit un retrait soit défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur vous
retirer vous maintenant je mets donc aux
voiles cet amendement avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 23 mai ses clés
rouge la présidente le sénat s'est dotée
d'un outil de consultation des élus
locaux en ligne il ya un intérêt certain
et dans ce cadre cet amendement propose
que justement dans le cadre de la
conférence des présidents au début de
chaque session ordinaire ils puissent
avoir un les modalités d'un droit de
tirage
s'agissant du recours à 7 à cette
plateforme et l'amendement propose en
complément que lorsque la consultation a
lieu elle donne lieu au dépôt d'une
proposition de loi une proposition de
résolution qui est inscrite à l'ordre du
jour du sénat à la demande du groupe qui
en est à l'initiative
merci chers collègues mais c'est le
rapporteur avis défavorable parce que en
réalité la plate forme de consultation
des élus locaux est un outil
institutionnel au service de
l'institution sénatoriales et pas au
service des partis politiques
chaque parti politique chaque groupe
dispose
de sa propre organisation de ses propres
moyens de communication et de sa façon
de faire pour informer les concitoyens
de leur initiative
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'avis défavorable merci monsieur que
rouge pour explication de vote
ça ne suis désolé mais l'explication
l'explication qui a été donné par le
rapporteur ne tient pas c'est pas une
question de consultation politique c'est
la faculté pour les groupes
c'est un outil du sénat je le rappelle
c'est pas l'outil que de la majorité du
sénat faut pas l'oublier et donc la
perspective c'est que chacun des groupes
puissent éventuellement lancer une
consultation des élus locaux
qu'on ne me dise pas que comme le disent
pas que ça pose un problème particulier
sauf à considérer que dans ce cas là
c'est effectivement l'outil de la
majorité les choses sont claires et
c'est réglé assez buffet
quand on lui qui est institutionnel ce
sont les commissions les délégations qui
utilisent ce moyen de communication
c'est bien une communication dont qui
appartient à l'organisation de la maison
ce n'est pas en fonction de qui préside
telle commission ou telle délégation ou
à telle responsabilité c'est en fait une
organisation interne de la maison une
communication interne de la maison en
aucun cas c'est une communication de
partis politiques
merci monsieur karoutchi pour
explication de vote
malgré cela je dois dire je comprends
même pas l'amendement
parce que toutes les collectivités
toutes les institutions ont des sites
internet institutionnels ce qui
n'empêche pas les groupes politiques
d'avoir leur propre communication leur
propre système de consultation que le
groupe socialiste que le groupe ait
l'air que le groupe centriste fasse une
consultation des élus mettent en place
un c'est un site internet pour le faire
il ya zéro problème mais si on commence
à dire que c'est le site officiel de
l'institution qui doit entre guillemets
être politisée par le fait d'affaires
année après année un groupe politique
vous compliquez sacrément la tâche
laissons l'institution fonctionné comme
elles fonctionnent et que chaque groupe
politique prenne la responsabilité de sa
communication et ses consultations mais
ne mélangeons pas les genres
parce qu'à la fin on va plus bien savoir
qui fait quoi si monsieur le président
on
je mets donc aux voix cet amendement 23
avec un avis défavorable qui votent pour
contre l'abstention il donc pas adopter
le numéro 5 quels amendements 5 présenté
par madame goulet oui monsieur le
président il s'agit d'un petit problème
de pluralisme lors de votre résolution
il n'est pas rare que la discussion
générale va l'explication de vote
il n'est pas rare non plus que un seul
orateur par groupe soit désigné en
conséquence de quoi si par hasard au
niveau des groupes il y avait quelqu'un
qui n'était pas d'accord
non seulement il n'a pas de temps de
parole à la tribune mais en plus il n'a
pas d'explications de vote ce qui est
quand même pose un léger problème donc
jadis il y avait une délibération une
résolution sur l'indépendance de la
palestine où il y avait eu effectivement
un orateur par groupe
la discussion générale va les
explications de vote mais derrière on
avait ouvert à des rappels au règlement
qui avait valu explications de vote
ah ben oui ça a été comme ça lors d'un
débat sur l'indépendance du nagorno
karabagh au mois de novembre dernier
cette fois ci il n'y avait pas de
possibilité d'explication de votre need
rappels au règlement et mais quand même
des gens qui n'étaient pas d'accord en
tous les cas moi je n'étais pas d'accord
donc cette je profite donc de la réforme
du règlement pour oui eh ben j'ai le
droit
je suis la seule de mon espèce j'ai
quand même le droit d'avoir une opinion
divergente
voilà voilà donc mais ça peut ça peut se
passer pour d'autres choses aussi bien
il n'y a pas que ce problème des
conflits non jeu des dégelées du caucase
donc voilà donc la l'amendement propose
que lorsque il ya des opinions divergent
ce qui n'est pas pu s'expliquer il y au
moins l'ouverture d'explications de vote
en fin de discussion générale ce qui
semble pas du tout porté atteinte à
l'équilibré des débats ni autant réservé
aux minorités
merci chers collègues mais cela rapporte
nous sommes dans le cadre des
dispositions de l'article 34-1 de la
constitution
la conférence des présidents peut
effectivement décidé que les
interventions des différents orateurs
val explications de vote
nous souhaitons tous les cas la
commission a cité indiqué qu'elle
souhaitait laisser la liberté aux
groupes politiques qui sont tous
représentés au sein de l'instance de
décider ce qu'ils voulaient faire
il est toutefois possible d'ailleurs il
faut le rappeler que plusieurs orateurs
s'exprime au nom d'un même groupe
ce qui permet le cas échéant de gérer
les opinions divers différentes au
divergentes
dans tous les cas c'est la liberté
laissée aux groupes d'organiser ses
interventions comme ils le souhaitent et
de gérer ses membres comme il le
souhaite également
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
émis un avis défavorable
madame boulet pour l'explication de vote
oui en rappelant qu'on peut avoir raison
contre tous
j'ai retiré mon amendement d'accès une
façon l'amendement numéro 22
présentée par monsieur kerrouche merci
madame la présidente
la perspective de cet agrément de cet
amendement est tout simple c'est de
vérifier les dispositions qui sont
relatives au dépôt des amendements
parce que avec un horodatage nous serons
en situation de vérifier que tout le
monde respecte bien la règle et les
limites de dépôt d'amendements
régulièrement il y a des soucis en ce
qui concerne notamment les rapporteurs
il semblerait par exemple un dernier
exemple en date que en ce qui concerne
le psg allait climat il ya des
amendements rapporteur qui sont apparus
dans le week-end alors que le délai
limite de dépôt était fixée à jeudi à
midi je pense que la meilleure des
choses c'est que les rapporteurs comme
les autres respectent les règles merci
cher collègue monsieur rapporteur c'est
un avis défavorable d'avoir ça ne relève
pas du règlement première chose et
deuxième chose il existe un dispositif
de rodage au sein de la maison pour les
amendements dont quelque part votre
demande est satisfaite aussi donc
défavorable
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement numéro 22 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour contre
abstentions il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 52 présenté par la
présidente a saisi un monsieur layec
merci madame la présidente
le présent amendement vise à garantir le
droit amendements depuis plusieurs
années effectivement nous assistons à
une dérive inquiétante concernant les
l'utilisation d irrecevabilité
consécutive donc à l'égard de ces
amendements
je rappelle une nouvelle fois le droit
d'amendement constitue une prérogative
constitutionnelle majeure le renier
c'est s'attaquer aux pouvoirs du
parlement
nous avons donc souhaité par le dépôt de
plusieurs amendements sur ce thème
volontairement est écarté par le groupe
de travail à l'origine de la proposition
de résolution
car ils auraient dû selon nous être au
centre du débat
cet amendement porte sur l'application
de l'article 45 de la constitution
quel est le champ du droit d'amendement
par rapport au projet ou une proposition
d'année en année les règlements des
assemblées et conseil constitutionnel
ont réservé la recevabilité des
amendements 14 l'objet d'un texte au nom
d'un combat contre les cavaliers
législatifs la question du lien d'un
amendement avec le texte est une
question subjective
nous notons dans les consignes qui
parviennent au groupe avant tel ou tel
débat pour l'application de l'article 45
une très grande diversité
ted approche pourquoi réduire à ce point
depuis des années la possibilité de
déposer sur un sujet donné des
propositions alternatives qui s'écarte
du texte pris à la dette mais portent
parfois sur le même objet nous proposons
donc par cet amendement d'être précis
pour garantir le droit d'amendement
merci monsieur le sénateur lahellec
meilleur à porter j'étais un avis
défavorable
on doit à la vérité que son un débat sur
l'article 45 et des conditions
d'application de l'article 45 auquel cas
on peut avoir ce débat mais on ne l'aura
pas c'est pas l'objet de notre travail
de cet après midi et puis très
sincèrement sur le fond on ne voit pas
bien la différence
en tous les cas elle n'est pas
d'évidence avec la rédaction actuelle de
notre règlement dans ces conditions là
on a émis un avis défavorable
je redis soit une demande de retrait
parce que je pense qu'en fait c'est
satisfait soit un avis défavorable
après si on va avoir un débat soit raté
45 c'est une autre discussion nécessaire
pour explication de vote puisque
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois nous dise si on veut avoir un
débat sur l'article 45 et ion le je ne
crois pas traduire en une autre occasion
monsieur karoutchi
mais je pense que c'est très nécessaire
parce que ce que nos collègues du groupe
communiste propose finalement c'est
d'écrire dans le règlement ce que dit la
constitution
que dit la constitution c'est que les
amendements sont recevables
dès lors qu'ils ont un rapport même
indirect avec le texte et quant au sein
du sénat
on demande aux pauvres rapporteur de
commencer par nous infligeaient un laïus
sur le périmètre au sein duquel on
aurait le droit de proposer des
amendements
je fais remarquer que cette pratique
n'est pas tout à fait conforme ce que
dit la constitution qui dispose qu il
peut y avoir un rapport
même indirect il doit y avoir des
amendements qui n'entre pas dans le
périmètre qui maintenant nous est
infligée et qui ont un rapport même
indirect avec le texte merci c'est le
président karoutchi vous avez demandé la
parole pour explication devenue madame
la présidente je reconnais la subtilité
du questeur sûr il dit vous mettez dans
le règlement en fait l'article 45 de la
constitution non vous mettez dans le
règlement une interprétation de
l'article 5 de la constitution ce qui
n'est pas exactement la même chose sur
le questeur donc c'est pas par un
article du règlement intérieur du sénat
que vous pouvez modifier la rédaction de
l'article 45
comme je suis aussi de ceux qui voient
leurs amendements parfois frappées par
l'article 45
moi je demanderais pas mieux qu'on
réfléchisse si les réformes
constitutionnelles à une nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 45 voire à une
nouvelle rédaction de l'article 40 pour
élargir les pouvoirs du parlement
mais c'est pas du tout l'objet du débat
dans le règlement intérieur le règlement
du sénat ne peut pas nier interpréter ni
modifier la constitution
merci nous prenons acte du fait qu'il
faudra bien avoir le débat un jour je
prends acte de cette annonce de ses
interventions et je propose que nous
retirions l'amendement un moment ont
retiré un amendement 40 présenté par
mais cela il est oui cet amendement donc
reprend une proposition ancienne mais
renforcée par la multiplication d
irrecevabilité on y revient en
particulier financières l'arbitraire qui
prévaut parfois exige qu'un débat ait
lieu lorsque les risques ni recevabilité
en l'occurrence au nom de l'article 45
pardonnez-moi encore l'article 45 et
soulevé en séance publique
cela paraît d'autant plus nécessaire que
si le recevabilité n'a pas été soulevée
au moment du dépôt de l'amendement
je ne parle pas des amendements du
gouvernement bien sûr c'est qu'elle
n'est pas évidente
le doute étant là le débat là aussi est
nécessaire et c'est le sens de cette
amende
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporta
juste un avis défavorable cela vise à
supprimer à la commission la possibilité
d'appliquer les dispositions de
l'article 45 je rappelle d'ailleurs pour
compléter le débat précédent que les
conditions qui sont fixés pour appliquer
l'article 45 sont visés dans l'article
en d'aller au sein de l'alinéa 3 de
l'article 44 bis du règlement intérieur
donc il faut laisser aux commissions de
la possibilité de continuer d'appliquer
la disposition l'article 45
je rappelle par ailleurs que le nombre
est extrêmement limité au regard du
volume d'amendements qui sont déposés
j'ai pas le chiffre exact en tête à cet
instant mais enfin il est assez assez
modeste et que je rappelle aussi parce
que ce sera peut-être l'objet d'une
discussion de valeurs que chaque
amendement faisant l'objet d'un article
45 et parfaitement publié est connue de
tous merci vous demander la parole lancé
le sénateur alors je mets donc on voit
cet amendement numéro 40 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour contre
l'abstention il n'est pas adopté
monsieur là et les cups présentation
d'amendements numéro 46 oui cet
amendement numéro 46 vise à restreindre
la possibilité de dépôt à tout moment
pour les rapporteurs et le gouvernement
en séance publique le débat là n'est pas
exception exceptionnel mais l'un d'entre
eux est l'absence de représentant par
exemple du gouvernement en séance
et pour cause nous sommes souverains ici
au sénat toutefois nous nous délections
bien aisément de ces bribes de
souveraineté et j'en veux pour exemple
la capacité octroyé au gouvernement de
déposer des amendements à n'importe quel
moment sur ses projets de loi mais
également sur nos propositions de loi
cette pratique consacre un déséquilibre
important entre pouvoir exécutif et
pouvoir législatif
notre président gérard larcher déclaré
justement lors des voeux de 2020 je le
cite que le sénat continuera à être je
l'espère un contre-pouvoir sans lequel
aucune démocratie ne peut exister
fin de citation avec de telles
possibilités totalement injustifiables
et avec des pratiques qui ne cesse de
s'accroître
comment ne pas considérer que la bonne
tenue de nos travaux est entravée nous
avons tous ces sites assister à la
présentation d'un amendement du
gouvernement
nous n'avions pu prendre connaissance en
amont qui mériterait un temps d'examen
approfondi
nous ne pouvons pas ainsi légiférer au
doigt mouillé
nous proposons donc le gouvernement
soient astreints aux mêmes règles que
tous les membres de ce parlement
et c'est le sens de cet amendement à la
glace et le rapporteur et vous chers
collègues c'est un avis défavorable
parce qu'en réalité votre amendement est
contraire aux dispositions de l'alinéa
13 de la loi organique du 15 avril 2009
qui prévoit expressément c'est très
clair que le délai limite de séance ne
s'applique pas aux amendements déposés
par le gouvernement ou par la commission
saisie au fond des limitations
d'ailleurs du droit d'amendement serait
inconstitutionnelle au demeurant dans
ces conditions la vie et des favoris
mais monsieur le rapporteur
vous maintenez l'amendement bien sûr
vous voulez une explication de vote non
comme merci donc je mets donc voit cet
amendement numéro 46 avec un avis
défavorable qui vote pour qui votre
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté j'ai à présent cinq amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune i nous commençons par
l'amendement numéro vins présentés par
monsieur kerrouche merci madame la
présidente cet amendement est à la
hauteur de la frustration générée par
les rires stabilité et donc la
perspective c'est de durcir les règles
qui encadrent celle ci est donc de
prévoir au stade de la commission le
fait que le président de la commission
qui est saisie au fond communique la
liste des amants n'ont donc lui propose
les recevabilité
mais 24 heures au moins avant la réunion
de la commission en motivant bien sûr
fut ce refus pardon oui concernant la
séance l'amendement prévoit un
dispositif similaire en ce qui concerne
les irrecevabilité au titre de l'article
45 comme en ce qui concerne l'article 40
il ya la possibilité pour tout sénateur
de contester en séance une déclaration
d'irrecevabilité
il n'en est pas question mais il revient
alors à l'assemblée de se prononcer sur
cette réalité sauf en cas d'accord entre
la commission des finances et le
gouvernement sur la déclaration
d'irrecevabilité
bref l'idée tout simplement d'encadrer
celle ci parce qu'elle empêche tout
simplement l'exercice du travail
parlementaire et qu'elles ont put
toujours un peu plus notre capacité
d'initiative merci chers collègues
la maman numéro 38 madame barailla ce
lit dans l'amendement numéro 30 38
traite de la suppression de la
possibilité de dépôt a tout mon monde
pour le gouvernement commission jusqu'au
chapitre 15 du prince machiavel montre
dans quelles conditions le pouvoir
s'acquiert où se conserve dans les
principautés mais plus que dans les
républiques ils dépendent des vertus
propres du gouvernant par vertu il faut
ainsi entendre les capacités qu'elle
soit morale ou non d'exercice de la
décision laisser au gouvernement le
droit la possibilité en droit de déposer
à tout moment de l'examen en commission
fait reposer bien grandes conséquences
sur les vertus de nos gouvernants comme
pour le dépôt en séance publique que
nous contestions d'ailleurs à
l'amendement 46 nous estimons que
l'exercice démocratique que constitue
l'examen d'un texte ne peut souffrir
d'un tel déséquilibre qui plus est
lorsque l'on sait la disproportion de
moyens entre la majorité et l'opposition
1,9 million de fonctionnaires au
ministère susceptibles de contribuer à
l'élaboration des textes si on ajoute à
cela
l'effectif des 324 collaborateurs des
cabinets ministériels qui ne cessent de
repartir à la hausse
le décalage est criant au delà des
moyens matériels il s'agit du modelage
de l'ordre du jour et des outils
constitutionnels pour en accroître la
portée
le temps de parole incroyablement élevé
donc il peut se prévaloir
il y a des avantages dont les puissants
n'ont pas besoin même lorsqu'ils sont
maigres
ces privilèges injuste suicide de la
frustration la volonté des gouvernants
s'impose ainsi aux gouvernés et à leurs
représentants
sans que ces derniers ne puissent ni le
contester ni le discuter et bien loin
des yeux de nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes
nous nous trouvons pris dans un flou
législatif avec des salves d'amendements
qui tombe au dernier moment sans aucun
autre motif que la précipitation voire
l'actualité médiatique il est impératif
que le gouvernement attend de la navette
pour introduire de nouvelles
propositions ou à minima qu'ils
respectent les règles communes de dépôt
en commission et en séance
merci cher collègue monsieur kerrouche
l'amendement 18
merci madame la présidente la
perspective de cet amendement est de
simplement mettre en distribution les
amendements même quand ils sont
irrecevables de telle façon à ce que les
citoyens puissent prendre connaissance
du travail qui est fait quand bien même
encore une fois il y a eu irrecevabilité
merci chers collègues la maman numéro 42
présenté par madame barailla ce monsieur
lahellec madame à ça si il est défendu
il est défendu le numéro 41
allez-vous fait 40 ou 41 comme vous
voulez vous faire 40 et 41 41 le
calendrier parfait 41 à l'envi alors le
40e la présidente cet amendement propose
une amélioration concrète de la
procédure d'irrecevabilité déclenchée au
nom de l'article 40 les plus anciens
sénateurs ou ancienne sénatrice se
rappelleront qu'au début de
l'application de la loi durcissant
fortement les rues d irrecevabilité
il était proposé aux auteurs
d'amendements de modifier leurs
amendements pour échapper aux fourches
caudines de l'article 40
c'était une bonne chose qui permettait
parfois de déposé l'amendement modifié
nous propose un dispositif simple qui
permet de revenir à un fonctionnement
souple des prérogatives parlementaires
le président de la commission par un
avis écrit et précisément motivé avertit
l'auteur de la vie potentiellement
irrecevable une nouvelle rédaction
conforme à l'article 40 de la
constitution peut être présentés soit
une heure avant l'examen du rapport en
commission soient l'ouverture de la
discussion générale en séance publique
cette rédaction peut être perfectionnée
sans nul doute
nous attendons vos propositions en ce
sens chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur ces cinq
amendements et même le président sur ces
cinq amendements le vin le 38 le 18 42
41 c'est un avis défavorable mais je
dois quand même quelques explications de
me rappeler qu'à jos france du conseil
constitutionnel impose un contrôle de la
recevabilité financière
je cite effectifs et systématique au
moment du dépôt des amendements
en conséquence les amendements numéro 20
18 et 42 qui veulent distribuer et
publier ces amendements déclaré
irrecevable irait à l'encontre cette
jurisprudence
tout comme d'ailleurs la procédure de
l'amendement numéro 20 qui remplace le
contrôle du présent la commission par un
vote de la commission et autorise la
contestation en séance d'une déclaration
d'irrecevabilité financière en pratique
le président de la commission a adressé
un courrier à l'auteur de l'amendement
déclaré recevable à ce titre le
dispositif proposé pour l'article 45 de
la constitution cela va sans dire
par ce même amendement numéro 20 est
satisfait en pratique en fait tu envoies
avant la commission des amendements ce
type d déclaré recevable aucune exigence
constitutionnelle n'impose la motivation
des décisions d'irrecevabilité sur
l'amendement numéro 41 qui souhaite que
le président de la commission des
finances avertissent l'auteur d'un
amendement avant de le déclarer
irrecevable pour lui laisser le temps de
se rendre de le rendre conforme à la
constitution en pratique il ya déjà une
certaine souplesse et non pas n'est donc
pas utile de les cayes ne paraît pas
utile de rigidifier le processus dans le
règlement enfin à l'amendement numéro 38
et souhaite soumettre le gouvernement au
délai limite de dépôt des amendements en
commission
c'est évidemment je l'aï déjà dit
ailleurs non conforme à la constitution
petit point d'information puisque je
constate que mon temps de parole mais
sur les amendements au titre déclaré
article 45
quelques chiffres que j'aime me faire
donner sur l'année 2015 2016 y en a eu
103 2016-2017 146 2017-2018 80 2018-2019
388 et l'on rechute en dise 2019-2020 à
144 sur un volume d'amendements déposés
je ne détiens pas tout à fait enfin ce
qui est assez important qui est en
moyenne de pratiquement 10 me pour
l'année dernière et de huit mois l'année
précédente et de 8000 un peu plus de
8000 pour 2019 2020 voilà la proportion
ce qui vous donne un ordre d'idée des
dispositions appliquées par les
présidents de commissions de l'article
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président karoutchi oui
madame la présidente
en fait tous ses amendements sauf le 41
sont des amendements qui quelque part
disent clairement au gouvernement est ce
qu'il faut pas réformer la constitution
pour voir l' équilibre sur les articles
40 et 45 dans le fonctionnement même du
parlement
donc là dessus on est d'accord sauf que
à partir du moment où c'est pas dans le
règlement intérieur du sénat qu'on
refait la constitution
le débat tourne un peu à vide sur
l'amendement
41 c'est un petit peu différent et moi
je serai effectivement alors pas pour
rigidifier comme ça mais pour qu'on dise
qu effectivement le président de la
commission des finances
lorsqu'il utilise l'article 40 lorsqu'il
déclare un amendement il recevable peut
avoir un contact avec l'auteur de
l'amendement
pour lui dire dans quelles conditions
l'amendement serait recevable
ça me paraît en revanche relever du bon
sens et du bon travail parlementaire
mais c'est plus un fonctionnement normal
par rapport au président de la
commission des finances une
rigidification du règlement intérieur du
sénat pour les autres amendements
sincèrement on peut toujours remettre en
cause l'équilibré gouvernement parlement
mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas sur
le règlement intérieur du sénat qu'on
peut le faire
merci monsieur le président je vais donc
aux voix ces amendements l'amendement
numéro 20 qui votent pour contre
l'abstention il n'est pas adoptée je
peux considérer que les votes sont
identiques pour le 38 18 42 et quarante
et un jours merci chers collègues ils ne
sont menteurs vous adoptez la maman
numéro 44 présent à les faire collègues
merci madame la présidente donc dans la
même logique que d'autres amendements
nous proposons donc de renforcer
par cette disposition le respect de
l'initiative parlementaire je vous
remercie
merci madame apourceau poly monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis est un moment ce
de l'avis défavorable aux réalités parce
que aucune exigence constitutionnelle
n'impose d'existence d'un recours au
sein de l'assemblée qui pourrait être
mise en cause défavorable merci je mets
donc aux voix cet amendement avec un
avis défavorable qui votent pour contre
abstentions il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement le numéro 43 madame
apourceau poly
merci madame la présidente
par cet amendement nous proposons une
nouvelle fois de rétablir le débat
contradictoire concernant les demande
d'irrecevabilité fondée sur l'article 40
de la constitution
la chape de plomb de cet article
renforcé par la lolf directement issues
des exigences de la commission
européenne en matière de procédure
budgétaire doit être levé au moins
partiellement la référence à la
commission européenne est importante car
il faut rappeler à quel point
l'élaboration des budgets nationaux et
des ordres désormais contrainte par les
règles bruxelloise l'application stricte
de l'article 40 est le pendant du carcan
imposé au gouvernement pour
l'élaboration même du projet de loi de
finances qui rappelons le doit recevoir
l'aval de la commission européenne avant
même notre débat parlementaire
si le gouvernement incite peu de marge
de manoeuvre
pourquoi le parlement en aurait-il tout
cela doit bouger c'est une question de
survie démocratique
l'acquis la crise de l'aco vide en
faisant par exemple voler en éclats les
critères jusqu'en 2020 très contraignant
des déficits publics
pourquoi ne ferait elle pas voler en
éclats les chapes de plomb que
j'évoquais par cet amendement nous vous
proposons de contribuer modestement à ce
retournement de situation
si chers collègues me fera porter votre
avis
c'est un avis défavorable en fait c'est
une compétence constitutionnelle confiée
au président du sénat qui a seul pouvoir
de pouvoir le pouvoir d'exercer la
possibilité d'avoir recours si parfait
manama pour sa folie je suis d'accord
avec vous je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui votent pour contre
abstentions il n'est pas adopté a
maintenant 14 monsieur kerrouche merci
madame la présidente
cet amendement je voudrais expliquer
surtout par rapport à la façon dont il a
été présenté par le rapporteur président
de la commission des lois
la présentation était tout à fait
spécieuse pourquoi parce que c'est quoi
à quoi qu'est ce que vit cet amendement
tout simplement le fait que la
constitution prévoit je le rappelle
qu'un jour de séance par bonds est
réservée à l'initiative des groupes
d'opposition et des groupes minoritaires
la question de notre amendement elle est
toute simple c'est qu'est ce que
représente un jour de séance
pour le cdh à ce jour de séance qui
fondent les niches parlementaires
dans l'état actuel des choses le sénat
considère qu'un jour de séance et soit
le matin soit l'après midi nous
proposons par cet amendement de prendre
en considération la séance du soir pour
définir ce qu'est un jour de séance
cela ne signifie pas qu'une niche fera
une journée
cela veut simplement dire que lorsqu'on
va calculer le temps de l'espace réservé
on va partir une enveloppe globale plus
importante qui intègre les séances du
soir voilà précisément l'objet de
l'amendement
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
oui même le président en fait cet
amendement modifie de façon importante
le fonctionnement actuel de notre
institution notamment à l'égard
c'est-à-dire relevé des temps consacrés
aux espaces réservés pour les groupes
d'opposition ou minoritaires
il ya un changement de règle qui est
proposée par notre collègue kerrouche
aujourd'hui on fonctionne sur un quota
ou un volume d'heures
et la proposition qui est faite c'est de
passer sur un nombre de jours un jour
évidemment un jour c'est une séance de
l'après midi une séance suivante eu
helmand le soir qui peut être prolongé
donc au le calcul global si on regarde
ça laisserait semblable au delà de
quatre heures pour appréhender un texte
je ne porte pas de jugement sur la
proposition qui est faite en tant que
tel mais c'est un changement profond de
notre fonctionnement actuel qui mérite
s'il devait être débattue ou aboutir une
concertation plus large des copains
travail évidemment au bureau du sénat
mais en la circonstance par un
changement qui pourrait intervenir à
l'occasion des débats que nous avons cet
après-midi sur la modification de notre
règlement c'est la raison pour laquelle
soit c'est un retrait qui me paraît plus
raisonnable soit c'est un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
caire où je vous maintenant je mets donc
voir madame boulet pardon pour
explication dresse sur cet amendement
moi je trouve que c'est quand même un
sujet intéressant je comprends monsieur
le président qu'il faille réfléchir
enfin vous voyez quand on a un texte
comme on en a eu sur l'alimentation qui
prend pratiquement toutes les niches et
qui est un texte derrière qui désespère
ses auteurs parce qu'on n'arrivera
jamais à finir dans les temps impartis
qu'enfin g il ya tout ce travail là et
c'est très injuste pour les auteurs
c'est très injuste pour c'est une fausse
démocratie ce sont ces niches dans ces
conditions là parce que le temps limité
mais des vrais est vraiment très très
injuste pour les auteurs de ces
propositions et je pense que revoir le
dispatcher les horaires seraient
vraiment extrêmement utile ça éviterait
aussi que des textes importants se
télescopent et que les parlementaires
qui veulent intervenir sur le texte
numéro 2 pouces leurs collègues du texte
numéro un à aller un peu plus vite pour
garder du temps extérieur va vous voyez
très bien ce qui se passe dans ces
moments là donc moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on y réfléchisse de façon
très sérieuse que ça me semble une vraie
bonne proposition massacre hérault sport
explications de vote
nous avons fait cette proposition
pendant le groupe de travail et par
écrit
alors bon prêt va pas faire un pas faire
semblant qu'on soit on veut limiter les
droits de l'opposition est limité à
dives sénatoriales et on conserve le
système actuel dont justement les effets
pervers viennent d'être développées fort
à propos
par notre collègue goulet c'est
exactement ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est une autre c'est un autre mode de
calcul qui ne changerait pas
substantiellement la façon de faire et
qui accessoirement nous permettrait de
respecter à la lettre la constitution
puisque on peut se demander dans quelle
mesure la façon de faire actuellement
est la bonne dans la mesure où elles
limitent nécessairement la capacité
d'initiative si c'est ce que vous voulez
continuer à faire autant dire comme ça
merci monsieur président karoutchi
pardon à la présidente ne peux pas
laisser dire ça parce que franchement
vous avez le droit de dire ce que vous
voulez c'est fatigués mais franchement
au sénat contrairement à l'assemblée
nationale
les règles qui consiste à donner du
temps aux groupes d'opposition groupes
minoritaires les règles ici sont
beaucoup plus favorables aux oppositions
que ce qu'elles sont aussi à l'assemblée
nationale et pardon mais quel que soit
le président de séance
franchement il m'est arrivé de présider
les séances où on n'est pas dix minutes
près pour finir un texte il faut finir
un texte donc on le fait et on le fait
ou très volontairement pour ce n'est en
revanche modifié complètement le calcul
du temps pardon de vous dire là ça
nécessite autre chose que simplement un
amendement parce que ça veut dire en
clair que au nom des groupes
d'opposition minoritaires vous
récupériez d'après votre calcul
tellement de temps qu'en réalité les
groupes de la majorité à 6 6 6 les
groupes de la majorité auraient intérêt
à tous ceux déclarés groupe d'opposition
ou minoritaires
parce qu'en vrai si sir faites le calcul
au fait le calcul vous verrez que les
groupes mais s'ils s'y passe que vous
n'imaginez pas les gogos majoritaire n'a
en réalité pas de temps sinon d'être la
majorité du parlement
enfin ça c'est les élèves
un pardon mais ça vous pouvez pas par
amendement supprime et les électeurs
donc il faut respecter la règle la règle
elle est simple les groupes d'opposition
est minoritaire déclarés comme tels ont
du temps et on le fait de manière souple
parce qu'on n'est pas à 5 minutes à dix
minutes près mais si vous modifiez
complètement le système
outre le fait que c'est totalement
disproportionné par rapport ce qui se
fait à l'assemblée
c'est une vraie réflexion à l'intérieur
de chaque groupe
parce que ça veut dire quand même un
nouvel équilibre qui n'a plus de sens
par rapport un équilibre démocratique
entre les groupes politiques qui
constituent notre assemblée
je mets donc on voit cet amendement avec
un avis défavorable qui votent pour
contre abstentions il n'est pas adoptée
nous passons à l'article 9 chers
collègues avec trois amendements
identiques de suppression monsieur
qu'est rouge alors que la carotide janot
dire combien l'opposition étaient
respectées et forcément respectable
d'ailleurs au céda et nous nous en
félicitons
après mon cher collègue il s'agit pas de
dire que nous ne sommes pas conscients
du rapport de force et de ce qui résulte
des mesures en général comme vous on
sait compter et on voit à peu près des
conséquences maintenant sur cette
disposition en particulier c'est à dire
de supprimer la fin de report de
l'orateur enfin deux ans fan tourniquet
je peux vous dire que par rapport à
l'opposition
ce n'est sans doute pas la mesure la
plus subtile que vous comptez mettre en
place et justement elle revient elle
revient sur une attitude qui était assez
constante au sénat et je pense que
franchement le mieux à faire ç'aurait
été de haut dans l'vent et cette
disposition
merci chers collègues le président
malhuret pour l'amendement numéro 29
oui la même sens madame la présidente
à la différence de beaucoup des mesures
envisagées dans ce test et son camp
sensuelle celle ci a au contraire
cristallisé une opposition nette de 6
des groupes de notre assemblée lors du
groupe de travail c'est pas étonnant
puisque cette proposition est encore
plus la proposition 30 du groupe de
travail qui sera étudiée en conférence
des présidents et qui consiste à
remplacer le tirage au sort actuel part
dans l'ordre des interventions par la
règle de l'ordre en fonction de
l'importance des groupes qui reléguera
systématiquement les groupes les moins
nombreux en fin de discussions
aboutiront à ce que les interventions de
ces groupes seront désormais pénalisés
et j'allais dire marginalisés la règle
actuelle du tourniquet et beaucoup plus
démocratique elle permet que l'ordre des
interventions n'oblige pas à la loi du
plus grand nombre
c'est le système en vigueur à
l'assemblée nationale mais également
dans la plupart des parlements des pays
démocratiques
ces articles qui ne figurera pas dans
les propositions notre rapporteur ont
été introduites lors de la dernière
séance du groupe de travail par le
groupe des républiques aussi président
de groupe qui s'y opposer le président
des républicains a répondu qu'il
s'agissait de l'application du fait
majoritaire
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on vient de nous
répéter aujourd'hui et donc de la
démocratie il ya deux conceptions de la
démocratie celle traditionnelle qui
donne tout le pouvoir à la majorité et
celle plus actuelle qui consiste à
protéger les droits des minoritaires
comme l'a expliqué tout à l'heure vanina
paoli en citant albert camus c'est la
conception qui règne aujourd'hui au
sénat et qui lui donne une ambiance
particulière tenant notamment au respect
et à l'attention accordée aux petits
groupes ou aux groupes d'opposition
bien entendu comme notre collègue et
rouge vient de lire se donnent la main
sa grille mais ne remet pas en cause le
fait majoritaire
il traduit simplement l'écoutent que
nous portons aux sénateurs de tous les
groupes
quelle que soit leur taille c'est un peu
de cet esprit d'ouverture et de
tolérance qui s'en va avec ces deux
propositions un peu de l'esprit du sénat
c'est la raison pour laquelle six
groupes sur huit s'y sont opposés c'est
la raison aussi pour laquelle je demande
à mes collègues des deux groupes
majoritaires de préserver cet esprit
d'ouverture et de tolérance et de se
joindre à nous pour supprimer cet
article
merci chers collègues
l'amendement numéro 45 présenté par la
présidente assassines
si madame la prime à mme la présidente
le dispositif de tonique et permet donc
l'alternance des prises de parole entre
groupes politiques et il est consacré
par le règlement de 1971 il y à une
réforme du règlement du sénat en 2009
qui a introduit une exception au
tourniquet prévoyant que les premier
orateur désigné par les groupes appelés
à intervenir après les représentants des
commissions sont issus de groupes
différents de celui auquel appartiennent
ces derniers en pratique cela renvoie en
fin de tour nick et l'orateur issus du
même groupe politique que le ou les
rapporteurs d'un texte où le président
de commission
ce qui permet dans les faits d'avoir une
alternance des prises de parole après de
longs et interventions des groupes
majoritaires qui sont en général
rapporteur sur les textes en séance or
cet article propose de mettre fin à ce
système d'exception en revenant à
l'ordre classique pour tous les orateurs
sont qu' aucune raison rationnelle de
soit vraiment avancé pour l'expliquer
alors pour notre part nous y voyons deux
raisons pour maintenir cette exception
l'alternance des prises de paroles
bénéficie au pluralisme des idées et aux
groupes d'opposition puisqu'elle permet
d'entendre les orateurs des dix groupes
à un stade peu avancé de la discussion
générale les orateurs intervenant en fin
de discussion ne recueillant pas
toujours et vous le savez bien
une attention aussi à suis assidus que
les premiers orateurs mais cette
exception est également à la faveur des
groupes majoritaires puisqu'il permet à
ceux-ci d'intervenir à plusieurs moments
de la discussion générale parfois même
en réponse à d'autres groupes qui se
seraient déjà exprimé cela semble
préférable à l'option d'un discours
monochrome dès le début de la discussion
générale après dix minutes de rapport
donc nous pensons que aucune logique ne
vient expliquer cette modification du
règlement et ce retour en arrière si ce
n'est le renforcement encore une fois je
le répète du fait majoritaire
merci chers collègues et ma soeur à
partr la présence d'un avis défavorable
sur ces trois amendements je reviens
simplement sur quelques explications
le principe actuel c'est que le premier
orateur de la discussion générale ne
peut pas appartenir au même groupe que
le rapporteur du texte et que la
modification qui est proposé ce n'est
entre guillemets que celle-ci
modifications parce comment les choses
vont se passer avec les dispositifs qui
est proposé est bien le principe du
tirage au sort continuera de fonctionner
et qu'il adviendra que parfois le
rapport le premier orateur sera
effectivement issu du même groupe mais
pas toujours et qu'il y aura un autre
orateur d'un autre groupe et c'est
parfaitement légitime le fruit du hasard
faisant son oeuvre
faut-il rappeler que enfin peut-être
rappeler que lorsque le rapporteur
s'exprime à la tribune d'ailleurs quelle
que soit son appartenance politique il
s'exprime non pas au nom de son
mouvement de son groupe politique
il s'exprime au nom de la commission
qu'il représente et à chaque fois
d'ailleurs on peut constater que quelles
que soient les uns ou les autres
qui est qui participent ou qui seul ou
en tous les cas amenés à intervenir
de cette manière la position de la
commission est parfaitement respecté
quelles que soient la commission et ce
n'est jamais une discussion de caractère
politique ou rarement en tous les cas
donc la proposition nouvelle c'est celle
ci et la commission des lois a considéré
qu'elle était parfaitement acceptable et
que donc d'avis sur les trois
amendements qui viennent d'être déposés
sont défavorables merci mais c'est sûr
vous a demandé la parole pour
explication de vote
oui madame la présidente
il m'est arrivé dans des temps anciens
d'assister à des débats ou deux
ministres ou trois ministres s'exprimer
et maintenant de la même tendance
politique suivie de deux ou trois
rapporteurs et maintenant ces mêmes
tendances politiques suivies encore
orateurs alors il fallait attendre le
5ème 6ème discours pour entendre un son
quelque peu dissonant cela était mortel
monotone quel que soit d'ailleurs la
qualité des dix orateurs et donc il y a
dans le règlement actuel
cette sorte d'élégance que je tiens à
souligner qui n'enlève pas une minute
mes chers collègues pas une seconde de
parole au groupe majoritaire
rien simplement il s'agit de l'ordre et
comme l'a dit madame à ça si après tout
aussi vous parler à la fin c'est pas mal
parce que vous pouvez répondre à ceux
qui ont parlé avant mais j'ai lu
l'exposé des motifs de monsieur qui
rouge
j'ai trouvé très bien en relation avec
ce qu'a dit monsieur malhuret
ça se termine comme ça les groupes
majoritaires s'honorerait en conséquence
en décidant après réflexion la réflexion
est encore en cours de s'opposer à la
suppression de cet article 9
très franchement ça a été un choix qui a
été fait par deux groupes un groupe ou
de groupe
je ne sais pas contre 6 groupe à la fin
d'un travail qui a été mené en bonne
intelligence
je suis sûr que vous serez sensible à
cela est que par souci d'élégance
finalement vous maintiendrez le
règlement kobe les voilà je crois que
tout le monde comprend cela et je sais
que vous le comprenez vous même là je
vous parle avec le coeur naturel
merci madame la présidente bruni qui va
nous paraît aussi avec le coeur bat si
beaucoup madame la présidente
moi je confirme je confirme ce qu'a dit
sur le rapporteur et président de la
commission des lois sur le sur le fait
que le rapporteur il rapporte la
commission et que
en revanche l'orateur du groupe i
rapport pour son groupe et parfois même
dans les lois de bioéthique je vais vous
dire que c'est pas forcément la parole
du groupe et ça peut être sa parole
personnelle
alors j'entends bien que six groupes
contre deux groupes
finalement la majorité elle est de
l'autre côté mais en revanche moi je vis
à l'intérieur du groupe et le groupe
l'est républicain et je peux je suppose
chez vous aussi bas tout le monde pense
pas la même chose et moi je peux vous
dire que les collègues souvent ils
disent pourquoi nous on est s'il vous
plaît pourquoi nous on est toujours en
dernier et c'est parfois difficile de
l'expliquer et l'asthme et là ce n'est
pas grave il y aura un tirage au sort et
après donc là on continuera sur les
différentes dg est forcément un moment
donné ce sera vous ce sera vous les les
premiers aussi donc
donc voilà ce que ce que je voulais
souligner c'est vraiment pas pour
empêcher parce que vous vous conservez
votre droit de prise de parole ce patch
ou pour vous empêcher mais effectivement
c'est assez désagréable d'être toujours
en dernier et puis pour charmant
président mal sûrs et je vous dirai
revenez avec le groupe majoritaire et
vous n'aurez plus de soucis vous serez
le bienvenu
c'était mon message du coeur merci la
présidente monsieur ben asher pour
explication de vote s'il vous plaît
madame la présidente
mes chers collègues j'entends bien le
point de l'élégance et de la qualité des
débats du sénat
simplement il est assez particulier que
le nouvel adage serait la division fait
la force
plus vous êtes des petits groupes plus
vous divisez plus votre parole est forte
et ça et ça et ça c'est un tout petit
peu étonnant comme méthode de
fonctionnement on peut appeler à faire
des groupes plus forts plutôt que des
petites divisions qui permettent parfois
d'entendre finalement aussi la même
chose mais répétés plusieurs fois
d'abord merci
ces règles je vais donc qu'on voit ça me
fait président manu rées pour
explication de vote voulait répondre au
courrier du coeur juste qu'on me fait
des propositions il faut qu' il faut que
j'y réponds je voudrais répondre de
choses à madame bruni je le remercie de
me proposer de retourner au sein du
groupe majoritaire
mais je vais vous répondre très
franchement c'est pas avec ce genre de
mesure que vous allez me donner envie
d'y retourner
c'est pas avec ce genre de mesures qui
consistent à pénaliser à marginaliser
les groupes minoritaires que vous allez
me donner envie de retourner dans un
groupe qui se durcit c'est ce que c'est
exactement ce que comme ça que
j'interprète et que nous interprétons
tous c'est de cette proposition
je dois vous répondre également que ce
groupe est interdite appartenu pendant
quelques années et que très franchement
je n'ai jamais entendu quiconque
aucun sénateur sauf peut-être ceux qui
sont particulièrement des présidents de
commissions et d'hommes et les sénateurs
j'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un me diront
par l'an dernier sur sur les
propositions de loi parce que
bien entendu les groupe majoritaire
parle en premier comme on l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure au sein va pas en tant
que président en tant que voilà que
rapporteur et c'est donc franchement je
n'en je n'ai jamais ressenti ni
l'utilité ni la demande de mes collègues
lorsque j'appartenais à ce groupe de le
faire quant au rapporteur je voudrais
lui dire qu'il nous donne une très bonne
explication mais c'est une explication
parcellaires sur un projet parcellaire
c'est une proposition est une
explication sur la proposition 29 du
groupe de travail mais cette proposition
29 qui n'est pas celle qui pénalise le
plus c'est que nous votons aujourd'hui
elle s'articule avec la proposition 30
qui elle supprime complètement le
tourniquet relègue les groupes
minoritaires ou d'opposition à la fin et
qu'elle va être discutée en conférence
des présidents pour des raisons de
règlement ne pouvons pas la discuter ici
mais le problème la vérité la réalité
c'est que ces deux dispositions forme
d'un dispositif et que c'est ce
dispositif qui au total est extrêmement
pénalisants pour les groupes
minoritaires ou d'opposition
donc je voudrais leur répéter mes
collègues du groupe majoritaire qu'il y
a là un vrai problème
un vrai problème qui est mal ressenti
par les papas par l'ensemble des autres
groupes et que comme le disait on aurait
tord de douleur je ne me rappelle plus
je crois que c'est ce monsieur je
kerrouche ou non c'est jean pierre sueur
nous nous en aurions tous de garder le
fonctionnement très démocratique qui est
le le le fonctionnement actuel ce serait
plutôt un honneur merci je vais donc
qu'on voit ces amendements identiques
avec un avis défavorable qui votent pour
qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adoptées je mets au bois
l'article 9 qui votent pour contre
abstention d'articles neufs est adoptée
article 10 avec deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune a
maintenant numéro 10 présenté par m les
rouges oui on va profiter de la grande
compréhension de la majorité sénatoriale
l'idée est toute simple nous sommes
d'accord avec le fait que l'on puisse
baisser le temps de le temps de parole
pour la pour la lecture des commissions
de des conclusions d'une cmp
pour autant il nous semble que deux
temps à autre il doit être possible de
retourner à une discussion normale
s'il ya une demande particulière d'un
groupe pour que nous revenions à la
règle que nous connaissons actuellement
sans pour autant remettre la possibilité
effectué effectivement de baisser le
temps qui parfois peut être utile parce
que les conclusions et ses lectures de
conclusions peuvent être fastidieuse
merci l'amendement numéro un
présenté par le président requis et
l'immersion à brillante de mes chers
collègues cet article propose
d'instituer une procédure allégée
d'examen du texte élaboré par une scène
le p ne nions pas évidemment l'intérêt
de ce dispositif qui donne de nombreux
cas aidera à réduire le temps de la
discussion générale suit la dcmp est
ainsi à optimiser le temps passé à sept
week toutefois nous considérons qu'il
serait souhaitable comme c'est déjà le
cas dans de nombreuses propositions de
pouvoir laisser à chaque groupe
commission saisie au fond sur le texte
la possibilité de revenir les procédures
normales est par exemple prévu pour
l'examen des conventions internationales
ou la procédure donc en paix qu aux 6 à
8 des familles et les dix truites if he
applicables je propose que ce soit le
cas s'agissant des cmp afin de laisser
une plus grande liberté tant nos
commissions comme groupe politique
merci président c'est leur apportant
votre avis défavorable pour les deux
amendements on met en place un
dispositif de ce que je qualifierais
d'alléger de lecture de cmp
après notamment le cnp conclusive de
façon à gagner un peu de temps puisque
nous sommes mis d'accord
l'idée c'est que la modification
éventuellement des temps de parole son
organisation a été confiée à la
conférence des présidents
hélas les amendement visait à donner un
droit d'opposition afin de le cas pour
le premier soit présente commission
s'oppose en groupes politiques crois
qu'il faut laisser la conférence des
présidents
légitimement décidé en présence de tous
les présidents de commissions et de tous
les présents de groupes de l'opportunité
ou pas d'avoir une lecture poste cmp un
peu plus longue que celle qui sera la
règle
désormais ça me paraît utile on a vu
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'intérêt la
semaine dernière le retour de cmp sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui a été
réglé en accord avec tous en un peu
moins de 45 minutes dans des conditions
qui étaient parfaitement acceptable dès
lors que dit-on tous d'accord et quand
vous souhaitez conclusif merci monsieur
le rapporteur je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement numéro 10 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour compte
abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro un
même bonne marche messieurs ce faire
pardon je mets aux voix l'abandon numéro
1 qui votent pour contre attention il
n'est pas the d'opter l'article numéro
10 vous avez une intervention mais ses
soeurs sur l'article numéro 10
c'est sur laurence alors pour l'instant
je mets aux voix l'article 10 c'est vous
êtes un peu en avance comme si je vais
vite donc c'est pour ça vous devancez je
vais envoie l'article 10 donc chers
collègues qui votent pour contre
abstentions l'article 10 est adopté
monsieur faire vous avez une
intervention sur l'article alors cet
article madame la présidence cela n'aura
échappé à personne porte non pas sur
trente secondes
qu'est ce que c'est que 30 secondes donc
on passerait de 2 minutes 30 à 2 minutes
mais il ne vous a pas échappé que c'est
le dernier avatar de toute une tendance
lourde qui fait que l'on nie finalement
ce qui est éminent essentiel principal
dans le travail parlementaire voyez-vous
déjà madame la présidente
toutes les lectures de presque tous les
textes sous des lectures accéléré j'ai
vécu un temps au sénat et à l'assemblée
où ce qui était la norme 7 et qui lui de
lecture ce qui permettait de peaufiner
les textes parce que c'est notre rôle
cela est maintenant rayé sa même
commencé avant ce quinquennat je tiens
le dire mais je déplore cette tendance
alors on nous dit mais il faut aller
vite
j'ai même entendu des aux gouvernants
nous dire mais c'est trop long
c'est beaucoup trop long le parlement
même certains de nos gouvernants donnent
le sentiment que le passage au parlement
c'est comme quelque chose de nécessaire
mais dont on se passerait volontiers
alors voilà je plaide pour ce qui fait
la grande tradition du parlement en
france et je ne citerai personne parce
qu'il y a eu des centaines et des
centaines de parlementaires connus ou
méconnus qui ont pas
c'est leur temps à argumenter vous
comprenez argumenté corps madame boulet
disait mais c'est la vérité que l'on se
trouve aujourd'hui avoir écrit un
rapport de 40 pages sur un avis
budgétaire vous avez droit
trois minutes alors maintenant deux
minutes mais est ce que l'on veut d'un
parlement qui fonctionne avec
l'idéologie du tweet très court très
vite
ou est-ce qu'on veut se donner le temps
et le moyen d'argumenter
c'est la question qui nous est posée et
c'est pourquoi il serait très symbolique
que très largement nous refusions ce
nouvel avatar qui détruit toute une
tradition parlementaire en france
merci chers collègues nous passons à la
discussion de trois amendements
identiques de suppression monsieur
retiers l'amendement numéro 2 oui merci
ma présidente mes chers collègues cet
article propose une réduction du temps
d'intervention de 2 minutes 30 à 2
minutes pour les interventions de droit
commun
je crains que cette disposition sion
option pour et puissent venir en guyane
au débat et quel foyer salle ce même du
parlement taille soit rassemblée
certains masques ce changement serait
indolore puisque le temps moyen
d'intervention science ne dépasserait
pas les 10 minutes mais alors pourquoi
se priver
mais et 32 secondes puisque la plus
grande majorité des cas elles ne sont
pas utilisées
et au fond peu importe de savoir si les
2002 32 sont effectivement utilisées
mais c'est de savoir que l'on puisse en
disposer de savoir que si l'idée qu'on
expose t complexe nous aurons le temps
de développer suffisamment pour qu'elle
soit un dirigeant chacun un débat ne
peut être fait que le slogan c'est aussi
un échange de démonstration
d'argumentation ce sujet souvent
complexes en suisse est elle une telle
réduction n'est pas ça l'effet sur les
petits groupes tels que nous vous perdez
sur évidemment temps de parler limité
durant la discussion générale aussi
l'explication de vote la défense des
amendements sont autant d'occasions pour
exprimer et développer nos positions le
groupe dès ce
j'ai fait qu'en principe de n'imposer
aucune consigne de vote à ce moment là
laissant toujours là plusieurs de
liberté d'opinion ainsi cette can le
secteur va pouvoir avoir l'occasion de
s'exprimer dans des conditions
convenables
où comment et pourquoi je regrette qu'on
puisse que nous engagions dans la voie
de notre réduction de temps de parole
merci président wauquiez la parole est à
mesquer rouge pour l'amendement numéro
11 la présidente je reviens rarement à
hama les origines en termes
universitaire mais quand même ici il ya
plein de choses qui ont été faites il ya
plein de d'études qui ont été faites en
ce qui concerne le travail législatif
est touché aux règles du travail
législatif n'est jamais sans conséquence
il ya des études qui sont assez connus
qui montre tout simplement que plus on
touche autant de la loi et plus on
raccourcit le temps de parole plus cela
a des conséquences sur la qualité des
textes qui sortent
c'est aussi simple que ça après on nous
oppose l'argument que la discussion en
commission et en libre est on est on a
beaucoup de temps de parole en
commission et donc en fait quand on
arrive en séance et bien deux minutes ça
suffit puisque l'essentiel a été dit au
préalable
rien n'est plus faux rien n'est plus
faux dans la façon de faire la loi
il ya deux rythmes qui sont assez connu
un rythme qu'on appelle celui de la
politique invisible et à rythme de la
politique visible le rythme de la
politique invisible c'est celui qu'on a
dans les commissions politiques
invisible parce que s'il y a des
affrontements ces affrontements sont
limitées justement par le fait qu'il n'y
a pas de publicité et que d'une certaine
façon nous sommes relativement à la
marge de la constitution et que la delà
de la discussion pardon et que la
plupart des gens se réserve justement
pour ce qui est la politique visible la
politique visible c'est celle que nous
faisons aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle ce
que vous voulez remettre en cause c'est
justement le temps de cet affrontement
politique le temps de cette politique
visible et cela cela va strictement à
l'encontre de la façon de faire la loi
par ailleurs
vous acceptez sans le contredire le
principe que le fait de diminuer le
temps serait dans le registre de
l'efficacité or je vous mets au défi de
le prouver et je suis certain que
certaines et certains d'entre vous qui
vont voter
cette disposition aujourd'hui le
regretterons amèrement à partir du mois
de septembre il y a beaucoup de raisons
pour refuser une telle évolution qui est
une évolution de façade
si elle n'est pas éminemment
superficielles merci chers collègues
l'amendement numéro 47 madame a pour
cela merci madame la présidente alors
monsieur le rapporteur je ne comprends
pas nous comprenons pas avec mon groupe
cette pensée dogmatique qui amène une
nouvelle fois à réduire le temps de
parole des parlementaires à l'origine
déjà lointaine de cette proposition de
résolution était d'adapter la nécessité
du travail du sénat et une période de
crise sanitaire
au bout du compte l'une des mesures
phare de cette nouvelle réforme
un règlement c'est la réduction du temps
parole vous me direz 30 secondes c'est
peu mais c'est 30 secondes en moins mais
le débat est ailleurs premièrement si le
tank débat est contraint c'est du fait
d'une inflation législatif en
progression constante avec des pics
depuis plus de 20 ans c'est le pouvoir
exécutif qui étouffe le parlement et non
l'inversé comme voudraient le faire
croire
les partisans de ce dangereux concept de
la rationalisation du travail
parlementaire dont les synonymes son
réduction du temps de débat réduction du
droit d'amendement remise en cause de
l'initiative parlementaire et des débats
ensuite l'affaiblissement du parlement
dont la majorité elle-même dresse le
constat puisque chaque semaine exiger de
toute autre mesure que de raboter encore
le temps de parole et cette mesure n'est
pas dans la proposition de résolution
car elle relève de la conférence des
prix
10dans corsetée le débat de ce conte
partie de loi de finances dans une forme
de temps programmé nous constatons un
certain consensus entre emmanuel macron
le gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
réduire réduire les pouvoirs législatifs
réduire les pouvoirs législatifs du
parlement qui se fonde sur le droit
d'amendement et le temps de parole un
long débat est nécessaire pour
décortiquer les raisons de choix
politiques et ses conséquences sur la
démocratie
nous sommes bien loin dans la pratique
des propos du président du sénat contre
la révision constitutionnelle d'
emmanuel macron nous proposons donc avec
détermination la suppression de cet
article vous je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur les trois
amendements de suppression
le président nonobstant l'avis
défavorable que j'aurai votre amendement
chers collègues je suis d'accord avec un
des points que vous avez soulevé avis
défavorable pour les trois amendements
mais vous avez raison de dire que depuis
de nombreuses années l'inflation
législative est bien réelle en 1995 le
président l'assemblée nationale monsieur
philippe seguin propose de passer à la
session unique pour supprimer les
séances de nuit
la session unique a été imposée les
séances de nuit sont toujours là parce
que l'inflation législative des bruits
tout le gouvernement mais aussi disons
bien de nous mêmes à travers les
propositions de loi et puis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 à modifier à
nouveau les choses puisque ce n'est plus
le texte du gouvernement qui vient en
séance mais c'est le texte de la
commission
et il est vrai que les choses ont un peu
hot et de ce fait modifier et la
commission les commissions plus
exactement qui font leur texte le font
librement dans le temps qu'elle le
souhaite avec ce qui touche le rap est
tout à l'heure une liberté de ton et de
temps absolument totale ce qui fait que
lorsque l'on arrive en séance
on est plus sur le texte du gouvernement
on est sur le texte de la commission
philippe qui ont un peu bougé disons le
librement et puis la faction du sla tive
a continué le micro à peut-être survivre
à moi pendant quelques instants et
l'inflation y est il va continuer donc
l'idée qu'ils proposaient par la
résolution c'est de ramener le temps de
soutien d'un amendement l'implantation
d'un amendement et de son explication à
deux minutes au lieu de 2 minutes 30
pour terminer deux exemples la semaine
dernière nous avons eu je crois que
c'était lundi après-midi ou mardi
après-midi deux textes dans un temps
relativement court nous pensions durée
dans la semaine finalement ce fut assez
rapide pour une raison simple c'est que
d'avoir les collègues ont chacun
respecte et ce le temps qui lui était
imparti
mais surtout parce qu'il n'est pas
beaucoup d'articles les choses se sont
faites rapidement mais nous allons avoir
une expérience prochaine un peu
différente avec le texte climat qui va
venir
et puis le texte 4d qui viendra en
juillet où on nous annonce des milliers
d'amendements
il faudra bien arriver à travailler
correctement dans ces conditions là et
avec 2 minutes 30 on va voir ce que nous
allons vivre
peut-être que deux minutes suffirent end
en la circonstance raison pour laquelle
la commission des lois a maintenu la
proposition faite par le président
larcher
aux termes de cette résolution de
ramener de 2 minutes 30 à deux minutes
et puis je crois que au bout du compte
c'est le bon sens qui doit l'emporter et
que chacun se maîtrisent aussi autant
que faire se peut nous savons que c'est
difficile mais c'est possible voilà j'ai
dépassé de 6 secondes par dont le
président karoutchi a demandé la parole
pour explication de vote lui madame la
présidente je voudrais reprendre ce que
vient de dire le président de la
commission des lois la réforme de 2008
avait pour objectif de faire en sorte
justement qui est plus de travail en
commissions et moins de pression sur
l'hémicycle et c'est pour ça qu'elle a
donné la capacité aux commissions de
refaire les textes de loi donc on a
enlevé au gouvernement cette initiative
total qui l'avait en matière de projets
de loi et on le donnait au parlement
donc les débats ils sont par définition
d'abord un commission puisque c'est le
texte de la commission qui vient devant
l'ensemble des sénateurs
c'est un pouvoir extraordinaire
c'est un pouvoir considérable qui est
aux mains des parlementaires mais je
veux reprendre ce que disait le
président buffet si par deux sa part de
l'a7 ce nouveau pouvoir
on dit que en parallèle il faut laisser
comme je l'entends dire par le questeur
sueur il faut laisser beaucoup de temps
c'est vrai sauf que quand vous avez par
exemple le texte climat qui vient plus
de deux mille amendements en commission
probablement plus de trois mille
amendements en séance lorsque vous avez
eu en réalité que si je prend entre 2000
et 2020 un triplement je dis bien
triplement annuelle du nombre
d'amendements
vous avez le pouvoir de la commission
donc de tous les parlementaires de tous
les groupes de participer à la rédaction
du texte qui vient en séance
vous avez un triplement du nombre
d'amendements à un moment la
sursaturation du travail parlementaire
je suis désolé c'est pas ne pas
respecter le parlement que de dire tous
les groupes peuvent déposer autant
d'amendements qui le souhaitent
il n'y a pas de contrainte ya pas de
limite et c'est un droit constitutionnel
ce droit est d'ailleurs individuel c'est
même pas le droit des groupes
c'est le droit de chaque sénateur de
déposer autant d'amendements qui le
souhaitent mais si on veut avoir de
vrais débats en commission pour aboutir
à l'élaboration d'un texte de vrais
débats en séance qu'ils puissent est
quand même suffisamment fluide pour
qu'on puisse gérer l'ensemble des textes
de loi et comme le rappelait président
buffet moi j'étais avec philippe séguin
en 95 quand on est passé à la session
unique ça apparaissait comme une
révolution c'est finalement pardon de le
dire un total échec parce qu'il ya
autant de sessions extraordinaires
qu'avant on siège autant la nuit voire
plus qu'avant et on siège le lundi et le
vendredi ce qui n'était pas prévu dans
la session unique ce qui veut dire que
le temps parlementaire s'est
considérablement accrue est ce que pour
autant la qualité l'ampleur l'efficacité
de nos textes a considérablement évolué
depuis vingt ans je n'en suis pas sûr il
faut de la fluidité
merci je mets donc au monsieur chère
la présidente chers collègues je peux
être d'accord avec le questeur sueur
parce qu'il dit qu'ici il y à un art
oratoire et une argumentation historique
et cela participe complètement de la
démocratie que l'oralité
sauf que parfois et je peux commencer
par plaider coupable le premier il est
vrai que la lecture des exposés des
motifs pendant 2 minutes 30 jusqu'à plus
soif
durant de longues nuits parce que
défendue par la déco signataires qui
ignorent même le l'objet de son
amendement nuit à la qualité de nos
débats
alors entre les deux c'est vrai qu'on
voyait il faudrait peut-être trouvé une
solution intermédiaire que l'on se mette
d'accord suivant les textes
peut-être que j'entende très bien cet
argument mais tout de même il y à aussi
pour chacun d'entre nous un effort de
discipline affaires de concision et
comme le meules rappelait tout à l'heure
excellemment excellemment le sénateur le
rudulier il faut se référer à boileau ce
qui est clair c'est dense clairement
merci chers collègues je mets aux voix
ces trois amendements de suppression
avec un avis mais si l'alluré pour
explication de vote
monsieur roch et pour expliquer son nom
d'accord monsieur mayer j'interviens
après le président buffet le président
karoutchi qui ont tous les deux parlent
et pendant 2 minutes 30 + wii seconde
pense qui concerne le président de la
commission des lois et 2 minutes 30 en
ce qui concerne donc j'ai tendance à
penser que c'est parlementaire chevronné
estime que 2 minutes 30 c'est le
ans qui paraît à peu près normale pour
exprimer les positions qui est souvent
sondés sur des sujets assez complexe moi
ça ne ça me gêne pas et j'ai trouvé que
c'était très bien qu'ils utilisent leurs
deux minutes trente pour pour nous
parler ma première réflexion j'arrive
pas à comprendre comment les
parlementaires qui sont déjà sous la
vème république réduit à l'impuissance
est de plus en plus à la figuration par
rapport au gouvernement décide de leur
propre initiative de réduire encore
leurs prérogatives et notamment leur
temps par an ma deuxième réflexion c'est
que je ne connais pas de parlementaires
on vient d'évoquer le sujet qui ne se
plaignent souvent de la profusion de nos
lois et de nos codes et je connais pas
un parlementaire qui ne demande pas à
chaque gouvernement de réduire le nombre
et le volume des lois présentés au
parlement veut qui ne s'est jamais
réalisé c'est pourquoi je n'arrive pas à
comprendre la proposition de restreinte
de 30 secondes on disait tout de leurs
trente secondes ce n'est pas beaucoup
c'est 20 % du temps de parole de chacun
d'entre nous dont on ne peut prévoir
qu'un seul résultat c'est pousser le
gouvernement à proposer encore plus de
loi puisque nous irons encore plus vite
et nous vous c'est nous même à les
étudier et en voter de plus en plus à
l'exact opposé de ce que nous réclamons
depuis toujours je ne suis pas
masochiste
je ne vais pas voter pour réduire mon
temps de parole est celui de tous mes
collègues et comme je ne suis pas
schizophrène je ne vais pas voter une
proposition qui consiste à renforcer ce
que nous souhaitons voir disparaître
et je voudrais donc ces amendements
madame la présidente est celle ci
souhaitait prendre la parole pour une
explication de merci madame la
présidente je crois que c'est un débat
important ce qui nous occupe
à cet instant je pense que le président
de la je vais revenir à la révision de
2008 c'est vrai que depuis la révision
de 2008 nous examinons en séance
publique le texte issu des travaux de la
commission donc
excusez moi mais nous et que nous
examinons in fine et le texte porté par
la majorité sénatoriale
on va pas se mentir
dans les faits c'est comme ça sauf que
des groupes comme le nôtre je prends le
mien par exemple nous avons souvent deux
combats à mener contre le projet de loi
initial et contre le projet de loi le
plus souvent des fois il nous arrive
d'être pour mais c'est rare et à la fois
donc contre le texte issu le projet de
loi du gouvernement et contre le texte
issu des travaux de la commission
donc nous avons besoin mais c'est
simplement une question démocratique
d'expliciter d'un point de vue en
maniant les idées parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ici on n'aurait plus
droit bientôt de manier des idées voilà
on est pour on est content on s'abstient
mais on n'a plus le droit n'aurait plus
le droit d'expliquer d'expliciter les
raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
favorables ou pas à tel ou tel article
d'une dinde un texte cela dit donc je
dis faisons à faisons attention et ce
qui vaut aujourd'hui pourrait faire mal
demain je le répète une seconde une
seconde fois
par ailleurs le président de la
commission des lois n'a pas répondu à
une question que nous avions que j'avais
posées notamment mais je pense que 4 il
l'a posée aussi dans son intervention
c'est sur le fait qu'en 2006 15 et en
2019 donc là le conseil constitutionnel
avait édicté une réserve
d'interprétation sur cette volonté de
contraindre le droit le droit
d'amendement
donc j'aimerais bien si monsieur le
président de la commission des lois le
peu qu'ils puissent répondre à cette
question
merci madame la présidente madame goulet
vous avez demandé la parole pour une
explication de vote
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
président vous savez c'est comme des
étudiants aux examens
voulant donner cinq heures ils ont
besoin de 5h30 vous leur demandez 6
heures ils ont besoin de six heures et
demie il ya toujours des gens qui ne
peut pas finir dans les temps bon mais
enfin deux minutes trente je reviens à
ce que j'ai dit en discussion générale
ça correspond aussi à un temps pour
l'ensemble des sénateurs qui n'ont pas
élaborer le texte en commission et donc
il ya certains de nos collègues qui
n'ont pas été partie au texte de la
commission qui ont peut-être besoin
membres d'autres commissions de
s'exprimer un peu plus longuement sur un
texte qu'ils découvrent puisque s'il
n'est pas une émane pas de la commission
permanente avec elise
par tienne ça c'est la première chose la
seconde est ce que cette règle aussi
s'appliquer en matière de loi de
finances parce que ça aussi c'est
important de savoir si ces deux minutes
trente doit être réduit également
pendant le plf
parce que là aussi on a besoin de temps
pour est pour expliquer pendant le plfss
donc c'est aussi très important c'est
moi la question des trente secondes que
le principe même de la possibilité que
c'est de s'exprimer qui hélas ici en
question et on peut tous
moi j'étais déjà présente comme monsieur
karoutchi et ministre des relations avec
le parlement sur la réforme de 2008 où
il a beaucoup peu vrai où on pensait que
c'était une très bonne réforme pour
lequel on n'aurait pas besoin une fois
que les amendements ont été déposés en
commission dans redébattre en séance
publique
c'était l'idée est elle était bonne sur
le papier il se trouve que dans la
pratique ça fonctionne pas de même que
l'ordre du jour partagé
c'était une merveilleuse idée sur le
papier dans la pratique ça fonctionne
moins bien moi je crois monsieur le
président que dans la pratique c'est de
ces deux minutes ne fonctionneront pas
et puis par ailleurs on est parfaitement
capable quand on a fini notre exposé de
s'arrêter même s'il nous reste 45
secondes
merci cher collègue monsieur sueur pour
explication de vote sur ces amendements
sur le vote de ces amendements la
présidence mes chers collègues les lois
inutiles porte atteinte aux lois
nécessaires
il y a une grande profusion dans le
corpus législatif mais je vous assure
mes chers collègues que si on éliminait
tout ce qui est déclaration d'intention
qui n'a aucune valeur et aucun effet
législatif et si on éliminait tout ce
qui est réglementaire on gagnerait
beaucoup de temps je plaide pour qu'il y
ait sans doute moins de lois mais qu'on
passe plus de temps à travailler sur ces
lois d'autre part la civilisation du
tweet eux arrivent partout y compris
dans notre système scolaire et moi je
fais une grande différence
entre la déclaration en une minute deux
minutes on peut énoncer quelque chose et
l'argumentation est pour moi le
parlement et le lieu de l'argumentation
or vous comprenez qu avec un temps court
comme cela nous sommes arrivés à la
conclusion de l'introduction que déjà le
temps est terminé
vous comprenez l'argumentation ça permet
de voir une position d'expliquer sa
valeur une autre d'expliquer sa valeur
mais d'argumenter pourquoi je retiens
celle ci et pas une autre
et pourquoi les deux me permettent d'en
produire une troisième vous savez le
temps qu'on arrive au bout de cela et le
temps de l'horloge pendant longtemps
d'ailleurs il n'y avait pas de
chronomètre
on nous laissait parler trouvé ça très
bien mais maintenant le chronomètre
règne si vous arrivez avec deux
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça si vous
arrivez avec 5 secondes de plus on se
sent qu'il y ait un peu de remue ménage
là dans les rangs 10 secondes
mais s'ils ne vous dit rien pendant un
temps eux ou si vous dit quelque chose
ces deux minutes 3 mais ce qui compte
c'est l'argumentation en dehors de
l'argumentation
tout est inutile et sans valeur
véritable j'arrive au bout voyez chez à
peu près meublé parce que je ne voulais
pas qu'on me reproche de ne pas utiliser
les deux minutes trente sous nos cieux
malhuret vous avez raison voilà merci
merci je pense que tout le monde s'est
exprimé que nous allons pouvoir passer
au vote sur ces trois amendements avec
un avis défavorable qui votent pour
qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adoptées nous parlons
maintenant de deux amendements qui font
l'objet de discussion commune
avec l'amendement numéro 48 monsieur
layec
merci madame la présidente par cet
amendement nous souhaitons rétablir la
norme du temps de parole dans la
discussion générale à deux heures afin
d'inverser l'évolution de l'organisation
des débats au sénat qui tend à réduire
progressivement le temps de parole
autrement dit comme l'indiquent de
l'alinéa 5 de l'article 29 terre à
défaut de la conférence des présidents
et sous réserve de dispositions
spécifiques du règlement il est attribué
pour la discussion générale des textes
soumis au sénat et pour tout débat
inscrit à l'ordre du jour un temps de 2
heures et non buner ce tome parole et
temps imparti à la proportionnelle avec
un temps minimum identique à 5 minutes
pour chaque groupe et un temps de 3
minutes pour les sénateur non inscrit
il apparaît évident que plus la
discussion générale est courte
- les groupes minoritaires d'opposition
s'exprime par conséquent le travail
législatif doit conserver ses lettres de
noblesse et renier sur le temps
d'expression des parlementaires n'y
contribue pas merci vous pouvez présenté
l'amendement numéro 49 de repli où vous
l'avez fait dans vos propos je les fais
dans le propos vous l'avez parfait donc
je demande l'avis du rapporteur sur vos
deux amendements 48 et et amendement de
repli 49 oui même le président la
présentation sur l'amendement numéro 48
l'objet c'est que toute discussion
générale d'un texte soit d'une durée de
deux heures ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes à 1h30
et parfois moi l'idée c'est de laisser à
la conférence des présidents
le choix de décider si on reste seuls
mois comme sur le droit en commun
j'allais dire ou si on veut jusqu'à 2
heures ça a été fait sur le texte valeur
la république ou la conférence des
présidents d'ailleurs à l'initiative de
madame à ça si il faut le dire avait
demandé à ce que la discussion générale
soit de 2 heures et la conférence des
présidents elle avait naturellement
accepté contenu
l'intérêt du texte donc l'idée c'est
défavorable sur cet amendement pour que
ce soit la confiance du président qui
décide éventuellement d'augmenter en
revanche sur l'amendement numéro 49
on avait émis un avis défavorable à la
commission parce que il y avait en fait
c'était moi sur le fond que sur la forme
la rédaction de l'amendement tel qu'il
était proposée écrasait l'article rose
donc je vous propose d'émettre un avis
favorable sous réserve de modifier votre
amendement en indiquant que pour
compléter l'article rose et ensuite les
dispositions vous pour vous proposer de
façon à éviter l'écrasement de l'article
je parle pour la science qui a
parfaitement compris l'aspect technique
des choses au delà de moi même
d'ailleurs voilà sous cette réserve est
il favorable pour 49 très bien nous
retirer le car nous venons nous prenons
acte de la proposition donc et proposant
de souscrire la proposition qui me sens
donc je vous propose de retirer le 48 et
donc de modifier le 49 au lieu de
rédiger ainsi cet article par compléter
cet article par un alinéa ainsi rédigé
et le reste du texte est le même avec le
vôtre vous en êtes d'accord vous en
sommes tout à fait donc monsieur
karoutchi vous demander la parole
président je vous le concède mais s'il a
concédé la présidente vous sauvez le
voter l'amendement 49 parce que y'a pas
de raison sauf que pardon mais
vous mettez une pression sur les
présidents de séance à quel moment vous
considérez que l'application et
bienveillante pas bienveillante en
fonction des éléments
c'est un peu c'est un peu curieux on va
le faire et après tout je vais le voter
enfin ça va devenir sympathique alors
parle par avance je vous demande
beaucoup beaucoup d'indulgence pour les
présidents de séance
je réagis tu rajoutes traits de la
bienveillance tout résident de séance
merci donc on met on voit cet amendement
49 ainsi modifié avec un avis favorable
de la commission qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté monsieur lahellec deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 3 présenté par an
le président requiet oui merci alain
prieur et chers collègues ça y est la
madame d'orpi sur les 2 minutes 30
donc conseil de l'esa a été ôté les dix
minutes pour la défendre des amendements
mais par contre en gazon et 2002 30 pour
les discussions sur arte très très de
parole ces articles et sur la discussion
sur le vote final
merci président l'amendement numéro 32
présenté par le président gontard oui
merci madame la présidente c'est un
amendement identique aux 6 2 de repli 1
qui vise à s'opposer à la domination du
temps de parole de deux minutes 30 à à 2
minutes peut-être revenir sur sur les
débats qu'on a pu avoir tout à l'heure
en fait moi ce que ce que j'arrive juste
pas à saisir c'est en fait la raison de
cette diminution
c'est à quoi ça va nous servir de de
passer de 2 minutes de 2030 à 2 minutes
peut-être gagner du temps on a vu et je
pense que la séance aujourd'hui la bien
l'a bien montré
tout le monde ne prend pas cessé de 2
minutes 30 mais on a parfois besoin de
ces deux minutes trente pour expliquer
pour expliquer un propos moi j'ai jamais
vu d'abus ici dans en séance bien au
contraire je pense que chacun ait à la
fois raisonnable et responsable dans son
dans son temps de parole et qu'on est
quand même au parlement là pour discuter
discuter la loi et de diminuer ce temps
de parole c'est quand même se tirer une
balle dans le pied et je comprends pas
que ça soit nous qui faisions ça on a
plutôt intérêt au contraire à conserver
ce ce temps là ce temps de ce temps
d'expression et de discussion ici à un
engorgement liés aux textes je dirais
que c'est pas pas de notre faute c'est
aussi au gouvernement de s'organiser
en tout cas j'ai bien sûr voter les
précédents un amendement de suppression
et cet amendement qui est un amendement
de repli en tout cas au moins conserver
ses deux minutes trente sur sur la
défense des amendements
voilà est la preuve qu'on n'est pas
obligé d'aller d'aller jusqu'au bout et
que on n'a pas forcément besoin dès 2030
mais on peut la voir dans cette dent
dans certains cas et je pense que c'est
nécessaire de garder ce temps là merci
monsieur le rapporteur
oui ce site conciliation de nos deux
collègues qui poursuivent leur console
double un objectif mais avec des moyens
inverse puisque l'amendement numéro 3
limite la réduction du temps de parole à
deux minutes pour la discussion des
amendements là en entrant deux faits
totalement inverse
bon en fait la commission a souhaité
rester sur la proposition qui a été
faite par le président du sénat c'est
donc un avis défavorable
merci je mets donc on voit ces deux
amendements avec un avis défavorable qui
votent pour contre abstentions ils ne
sont pas adoptées je me revois l'article
11 ainsi modifié qui votent pour contre
abstentions l'article 11 est adopté un
article additionnel après l'article 11
l'amendement 51 présenté par madame
barrios merci madame la présidente cet
amendement concerne plus
particulièrement l'organisation des
débats budgétaires
l'amendement vise donc à préserver des
conditions du débat budgétaire en
contraignant la conférence des
présidents à faire respecter un examen
satisfaisante pour les groupes
d'opposition
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2021 était particulièrement
mouvementée
si bien que par une contraction trop
importante du temps parlementaire les
samedis ont accueilli l'examen de
plusieurs missions de plus de nombreuses
missions été mise en discussion commune
cette pratique permet automatiquement de
comprimer le temps de la discussion par
thématique de politiques publiques sont
regroupés parfois des missions qui en
vérité non pour similitudes que le fait
que vous ayez bien voulu les associer
il nous faut solennellement reconnaître
que l'on ne peut débattre en quatre
minutes d'émission gestion des finances
publiques des crédits non répartis de la
transformation et fonction publique et
des règles des régimes spéciaux et de
retraite la discussion générale est bien
la seule façon de débattre et de
contrôler les annonces et les projets
politiques du gouvernement pour chaque
poste budgétaire
en effet ce livre est la pratique des
amendements de compensation expose les
parlementaires que nous sommes à une
lisibilité et une incompréhension de la
part des citoyens qui s'intéressent à
nos débats
c'est pour cela que le temps de parole a
loué au groupe doit être préservée mais
plus encore renforcée pour garantir une
véritable capacité exprimer des idées
sans faire l'impasse sur des pans
entiers de nos politiques publiques
chers collègues mais c'est le rapporteur
c'est un moment de fixer des règles de
prise de parole sur votre finances
l'idée c'est de rester sur le fait que
la conférence des présidents en décide
gardons la souplesse qu'on va souhaiter
depuis le début merci merci je mets donc
aux voix cet amendement avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée jeu mais je vois l'article
12 qui votent pour contre abstentions il
est adopté je mets aux voix l'article 13
qui votent pour contre abstentions
il est adopté un article additionnel
après l'article 13 présentée par
monsieur kerrouche l'amendement numéro
merci madame la présidente la
perspective de cet amendement est de
revenir à l'interrogation que nous
avions initialement en réfléchissant au
règlement c'est à dire de prendre en
compte les périodes particulières qui
peuvent survenir
et pour que les choses soient claires
notamment parce que il ya une petite
confusion en commission la possibilité
c'est tout simplement que quelqu'un
puisse soutenir un amendement alors que
le sénateur qui l'a déposé n'est pas
présent sans forcer
forcément d'autres sénateurs a signé
celui ci juste une précision cet
amendement ne s'applique en cas de jauge
réduite en séance c'est à dire dans
l'état où les sénateurs qu'on sait
qu'ils consentent à ce privé de séance
pour des raisons sanitaires ou sont
privés de séance pour des raisons
sanitaires et il nous semble que la
question de la co signature n'est pas
une solution acceptable puisque on force
certains sénateurs a signé un amendement
tout simplement pour qu'il soit puisse
être défendu la possibilité de reprise
dans ces cas exceptionnels nous semble
une meilleure solution beaucoup plus
pragmatique
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur juste un avis défavorable de
la commission comme la vie d'ailleurs
été défavorable du groupe de travail sur
cette demande
je rappelle d'ailleurs que pour tous
collègues qui souhaite que signé un
amendement il peut le faire jusqu'à
l'ouverture de la séance ce qui fait que
de ce fait si celui qui est le premier
signataire n'est pas là il ya toujours
un collègue qui veut reprendre son
amendement et ça paraît quand même
beaucoup plus confortable de reprendre
un amendement auxquelles on croit pour
lequel on s'est engagés plutôt que ce
soit notre collègue qui à la volée
pendant la séance reprennent
l'amendement le défendre avec un risque
porter dans cette affaire-là quelques
finalement au bout du compte on
considère que n'importe qui pouvant
reprendre l'amendement il est plus utile
de venir en séance
c'est un peu un sujet sur lequel il faut
s'interroger donc avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur je mets donc
qu'on voit cet amendement avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour
contre l'abstention il n'est pas adoptée
nous passons à l'article 14 avec deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le 24 présentés par monsieur kerrouche
wii qui traite la question de la parité
qui est bien mal m'a mené dans le texte
qui nous est proposé l'amendement dont
nous parlons actuellement vise à
garantir une parité effective au sein du
bureau du sénat
ça veut dire que les listes de candidats
aux fonctions qui sont concernés
seraient en nombre pair en ce qui
concerne des vice présidents et
secrétaires et que la parité doit être
garanti pour lens pour ces postes pour
la liste des candidats à la fonction de
questeur l'écart entre le nombre de
femmes et le nombre d'hommes ne pourra
pas être supérieur à 1
alors là dessus il faut être assez clair
la plupart du temps et ça s'est vu
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble des règles
qui traitait de la parité
il ya toujours une impossibilité
technique pour faire en sorte de pouvoir
mettre en place la parité c'est souvent
la réponse qui nous est faite et je
m'imagine que c'est celle qui va nous
être fait à nouveau aujourd'hui un
moment donné un moment donné je suis
désolé mais il faut poser les tendances
et il faut se poser les principes et
l'intendance suivra où le plus important
c'est la parité et la capacité à la
mettre en oeuvre
ou alors on se réfugie derrière la
formule très vague et assez peu
contraignantes qui nous est proposé dans
le cette modification du règlement merci
monsieur sur l'amendement numéro 26 les
chefs collègues
pour le cas improbable où vous n'auriez
pas été convaincus par les
argumentations de monsieur qui rouge je
présente un second amendement parce que
c'est vrai que cette rédaction
selon laquelle on s'efforce d'assurer la
parité est un peu poussive quoi tout le
monde voit bien que ça fait formule de
circonstance qui n'a pas forcément
beaucoup d'effets alors ce qui est
proposé dans l'amendement numéro 26
c'est la chose suivante
s'agissant de la nomination des
secrétaires et des vice présidents au
sein du bureau soit un groupe dispose
d'un seul poste
eh bien on peut pas lui demander la
parité c'est normal soit ils disposent
d'un nombre pair de postes
et dans ce cas il est tout à fait
possible d'inscrire dans le règlement
qu'il présente un homme et une femme ou
une femme et un homme
soit ils disposent d'un nombre impair
3,5 et dans ce cas il doit bien entendu
désigner un nombre de femmes et d'hommes
correspondant à une répartition qui
fasse qu'un sexe soient supérieurs en
nombre à l'autre de 1 une unité
donc vous voyez bien madame la
présidente que l' avantage de ce
dispositif c'est qu'il est faisable
il n'assure pas la parité absolue en
raison de la ducasse de la question des
questeurs et on peut me dire que
naturellement dans l'amendement présenté
par monsieur crouch
il faut que les groupes se mettent
d'accord mais dans celui que c'est
l'honneur de présenter mais nous sommes
signataires des deux là il n'y a plus
besoin d'oublier d'accord entre les
groupes
il suffit que chaque groupe présente des
candidats de manière paritaire
donc ça fonctionne de toute façon et par
conséquent si vous voulez que l'on aille
au delà des formules vagues on s'efforce
l'arrivée
ah on fait en sorte de parvenir à et
bien il suffit de voter cet amendement
j'espère vous avoir convaincu parce que
c'est vraiment très simple merci cher
collègue monsieur rapporte à votre avis
c'est un avis défavorable pour ces deux
amendements d'abord parce que la
proposition qui est faite par le
président du sénat dans cette résolution
est une proposition qui tient compte de
deux facteurs ont certes une volonté pas
difficultés mais aussi des contraintes
les contraintes ce sont les groupes
politiques
on va pas aller si miss est d'abord un
dans la gestion interne des routes
politique première chose
deuxième chose les groupes selon leur
taille n'ont pas forcément la même
capacité à pouvoir répondre à cette
demande c'est la question qui me paraît
évidemment la plus importante rappelle
que pour le bureau aujourd'hui la parité
elle est parfaitement respectée elle est
respectée puisque les secrétaires 7 à
parité davis prudence et à parité
la question se pose pour la questure
mais ce ne sont qu'un seul poste proposé
à chaque groupe il ya trois groupes
trois postes donc une difficulté qui est
différente à cette hypothèse il faut
conserver le texte et qu'il est rédigé
aujourd'hui pour permettre d'atteindre
évidemment à chaque fois outre dès qu'on
le peut et combien de capter de le faire
en accord avec les groupes là le respect
de la parité
merci président karoutchi vous avez
demandé la parole oui madame la
présidente alors l'amendement de du
questure sûr c'est un amendement de
repli par rapport à l'amendement
guerrouj l'allemande manqué rouge est
impraticable mais impraticable parce que
dire que on veut la parité
lorsque par définition ça veut dire qu'
il faudra imposer lorsqu'on aura par
exemple le groupe ait l'air sous la
présidence de bruno retailleau nous nous
avons mis une règle il ya un vice
présidente europe un vice-président
femmes et autant de secrétaire sommes
que deux secrétaires femmes donc on est
à l'équilibré au bureau en homme femme à
l'intérieur du groupe
je crois que le groupe socialiste fait à
peu près la même chose parce que
justement vous avez aussi deux
vice-présidents et tout mais c'est très
compliqué pour les groupes qui ont un
vice président parce que si vous leur
dites à b désolé mais il y a huit
vice-présidents il ya déjà entre l air
et ps
deux hommes deux femmes alors sur les
quatre autres débrouillez vous il y en a
deux qui auront un homme deux cures ans
une femme et
c'est on va imposer comment donc ça
c'est impraticable sur l'amendement de
questeur sueur je comprends le côté plus
pratique
c'est extrêmement pardon hein c'est
extrêmement invasif si je puis dire dans
la vie des groupes
je crois que c'est à chaque groupe de
faire l'effort les grands groupes qui en
ont deux on fait déjà on fait déjà de la
parité et les autres groupe plus réduit
qui ont un vice-président ou tout au
moins de secrétaires ou un nombre impair
de secrétaire ils font tous les efforts
franchement je pense pas qu'au sénat que
ce soit dans le bureau du sénat ou dans
la gestion des séances
il est vraiment un problème de parité
ostensible laissons les groupes se gérer
eux mêmes merci chers collègues je mets
donc on voit ces deux amendements avec
un avis défavorable au numéro 24
l'amendement 24 qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté l'amendement de remplir
plénière au 26 qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui savent qu'un ne sont
pas adoptées la maman numéro 33 ces
présidents gontard oui merci madame la
présidente il s'agit d'un amendement de
repli pour aux deux amendements
précédent à cet amendement vient
préciser les les mécanismes favorisant
au maximum une certaine parité au sein
des bureaux du sceau sénat en compétents
article 14 par l'inscription d'une
obligation de parité lorsqu'un groupe
doit pouvoir doit pourvoir justement
plusieurs postes identiques au sein du
bureau
en effet le le règlement actuel n'évoque
aucune obligation de respect de la
parité dans ce cas précis et bien
effectivement qu'on observe en pratique
l'installation d'une coutume allant de
ce sens il convient justement d'en
consacrer l usage dans le texte on voit
bien que dans la rédaction actuelle de
l'article 14 n'est qu'une invitation
sans grande portée donc il convient de
renforcer sa rédaction
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable madame le
président nous sommes déjà expliqué
précédemment
très bien je mets donc aux voix cet
amendement numéro 33 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour
qui vote contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté je me revois l'article 14 qui
votent pour contre abstentions article
14 est adopté un article additionnel
après l'article 14 présentée par
monsieur qui rouge l'amendement numéro
pour faire plaisir à notre collègue
karoutchi sur les difficultés à faire il
ya justement on propose que il ya eu une
parité une représentation équilibrée des
femmes et des hommes
s'agissant des présidences de
commissions dans l'état actuel des
choses il n'y a que deux femmes qui sont
président d'une commission permanente au
sénat et là encore il y aura toujours
des difficultés puisque en effet en
effet les présidents ou les présidents
sont élus par la commission mais juste
une chose juste une chose si on avait
continué à raisonner de la même façon
quand la les différentes mesures les
différentes mesures sur la parité se
seront mis en place
on n'aurait jamais pu on aurait jamais
pu avancer et on a toujours
systématiquement cette prise de cette
prise de position laissant le temps
faire laissons les choses ne soyons pas
invasif
on a vu le résultat merci cher collègue
monsieur le rapporteur a présenté un
avis défavorable c'est toujours la même
explication depuis tout à l'heure on
team ispa dans le fonctionnement des
groupes et dans les désignations des
favoris merci je mets donc aux voix cet
amendement numéro 25 avec un avis
défavorable qui votent pour compte qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais
se voit l'article 14 bis qui votent pour
contre l'abstention il est adopté je
mets aux voix l'article 14 ter qui est
pour contre attention il est adopté je
mets au voile article 14
waters qui est pour contre attention il
était adopté un article additionnel
après l'article 14 quater présentée par
monsieur rapin
la maman numéro 28 la commission le
reprend sous le numéro 53
c'est surtout le président de la
commission des commissions c'est ce
pouvoir qui nous reste oui je reprend
l'amendement de notre collègue jean
françois rapin qui est le mouvement 28 à
l'article additionnel après l'article 14
quater qui souhaite que la commission de
délégation qui le président puisse
fonctionner de la même façon que les
autres commissions en matière de
publications à la fois de rapports et de
textes en clair les commissions qui sont
saisies habituellement d'un projet
législatif publie d'abord le texte de la
commission est tel qu'il résulte des
débats et ensuite quelques jours plus
tard où quelques heures plus tard le
rapport ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
notre collègue rap
enfin pour la délégation présidée par le
choléra pas qu'ils publient à la fois le
texte et le rapport le même jour donc il
souhaite pouvoir fonctionner comme les
autres commissions donc avis favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur
je mets donc aux voix cet amendement
numéro 53 des commissions qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre 6,7 stien il
est donc adopté enfin je mets aux voix
l'article 15 l'entrée en vigueur le 1er
octobre 2021 de cette résolution qui
votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je vais mettre
monsieur kerrouche oui je vais mettre
aux voix l'ensemble de la proposition de
résolution y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote j'ai enregistré
monsieur les rouches
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
brune
les images sont les rouches je vais
enregistrer en même temps mais c'est un
présidente non mais on va être très bref
sur quelques points
il me semblait qu'il était assez facile
d'évoluer et d'aller
vers quelque chose de plus consensuel
dans la mesure où sur les points les
plus sensibles qu'ils ne sont pas que le
fait du groupe socialistes écologistes
et républicains
il n'y a pas été possible d'avancer je
pense au temps de parole
et puis je les dis déjà à la mesure très
particulière du tourniquet
cela nous fait que confirmer que encore
une fois c'était une un texte de façade
qui conforte les pouvoirs de la majorité
elle a tout à fait le droit de le faire
on ne peut que le regretter c'est pour
ça que nous voterons contre merci
monsieur kerrouche la parole est à
madame bruni merci madame la présidente
je voudrais d'abord remercier la
commission des lois
sa présidente et son rapporteur d'avoir
intégré dans le règlement ce qui émane
en fait de notre groupe de travail
je pense que l'essentiel est quand même
sur les ordonnances et sûre sur les
pétitions et je crois sincèrement que on
a un meilleur suivi des ordonnances et
pour les pétitions je pense un meilleur
accès et une ouverture sincère pour tous
les français qui voudront s'en venir
vers nous sur sur le contrôle aussi je
pense qu'il ya des avancées je pense
qu'on s'est beaucoup focalisé sur sur le
temps de parole
je crois franchement que c'est pas un
sujet que l'efficacité elle et elle est
certaine et je veux bien entendre dans
mes cheveux bien entendre que
qu'on pense que c'est parce que on est
dans la majorité
moi j'ai fait un passage au parlement
européen où la moyenne elle est à une
minute dans l'hémicycle mais oui et les
discussions et les débats se font dans
les commissions avec de vrais débats
vraiment des échanges très intéressants
qui si finalement dans l'hémicycle quand
on appelle débat c'est très fort manises
et donc je crois sincèrement que c'est
plutôt dans les commissions qu'on doit
le faire et puis enfin sur sur la parité
bon moi je n'aime pas ce qui est
obligatoire
voilà donc donc la parité obligatoire
jeu je sais que si je suis là c'est
peut-être à cause de ça mais je trouve
ça vraiment dommage et moi sincèrement
je trouve que ça nous pénalise donc le
texte dit le favoriser et je crois
sincèrement que ici au sénat on peut pas
dire que on ne nous favorise pas pour
être dans les postes si on en a envie et
donc moi je voudrais remercier en fait
tout ce qui est con voter ici qui vont
voter ce texte et qui je pense permettra
d'améliorer aussi la séance merci à vous
merci présidente je donne la parole aux
sénateurs folio merci non la présidente
comparaison n'est pas raison
il y a quelques mois encore eux jugés
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
et je puis vous dire mes chers collègues
que j'ai pu apprécier la qualité des
travaux que nous avions ici dans cette
assemblée que ce soit en commission que
ce soit au sein de l'hémicycle avec la
capacité de chacune et chacun d'entre
nous de pouvoir nous exprimer de pouvoir
nous écouter je crois que c'est un
élément important et c'est un élément
qui caractérise et de différenciation
entre les deux assemblées
parce que toutes et tous au regard vous
dire la quasi totalité d'entre nous de
notre expérience d'élu local
il y a 7 cette façon de faire ce
sentiment cette notion d'écouté de
respect de l'autre et de faire de telle
sorte que nous puissions à l'instar de
ce que nous faisons dans nos différentes
collectivités faire de telle sorte que
nous puissions donc écouter et avancer
le plus sereinement qu'ils soient très
objectivement je ne voudrais pas ce
texte je ne voterai pas ce texte parce
que j'ai pu apprécier la qualité comme
je les dis du travail que nous avions
donc aux scènes du sénat et que dans ce
cadre là je ne suis pas sûr que ces
évolutions aille dans le sens alors
j'entends bien les arguments aux regards
d'éviter les cadres d'obstruction qui
sont réelles à l'assemblée nationale
avec des milliers d'amendements déposés
alors il ya certaines solutions qui
avait trouvé le temps législatif
programmé et autres je vais pas revenir
parce que c'est pas le sujet mais en
tout état de cause nous devons être très
prudents par rapport à cela je dis
simplement aussi n'oublions jamais que
la majorité d'un jour sera l'opposition
de demain et vice versa c'est le propre
de toute démocratie et que tout texte
qui est votée dans ce cadre là un jour
je dire saura peut-être regretter par
rapport à ses capacités à ces éléments
de pouvoir exprimer un certain nombre de
choses et je crois que personne
alors même si on peut regretter parfois
quelques éléments mais en global ces
temps de parole sont utilisés par
chacune et chacun d'entre nous avec
maximum et le plus souvent d'être
d'efficacité de perspicacité pour faire
de telle sorte qu'il puisse avoir
capacité de défendre ses idées ses
convictions
ce qui est un élément propre essentiel
dans toute démocratie
merci chers collègues madame la
présidente et ses six mois ci dans son
box
merci la présidente très rapidement à
l'issue de cette idée de ce débat j'ai
en fait je les dis dans la discussion
générale mais j'ai toujours du mal à
prendre le sens et la nécessité de cette
de cette réforme qui est bien loin de
répondre aux défis d'expression
démocratique qui traverse cette
nécessité ce besoin traverse pourtant
tous les bancs et bien souvent aussi
beaucoup de couloirs de notre
institution
je reconnais quand même ici au sénat et
cela vient d'être dit que une certaine
courtoisie certaine courtoisie règne et
il est heureux que nous ne soyons pas
les années jusqu'au temps programmé qui
est à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale et
qui tue à petit feu à petit feu
effectivement l'expression des
politiques des groupes et donc qui qui
lui en fait au débat démocratique alors
quand au parlement européen
alors ça parle aux hôtes du parlement
personne ne sait ce qui se dit ce qui se
fait au parlement européen
et c'est peut-être ce qui explique la
défiance d'un trop grand nombre de nos
concitoyens à l'égard de l'europe et 2
et de ses institutions
donc je pense que c'est ce n'est
peut-être pas le meilleur exemple à
prendre pour expliquer la réforme sur
laquelle nous avons travaillé cet après
midi merci présidente
je mets donc aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de résolution qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient
cette proposition de résolution est
adoptée en application du premier alinéa
de l'article 61 de la constitution la
résolution que le sénat vient d'adopter
sera soumise avant sa mise en
application au conseil constitutionnel
[Musique]